Recording the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by fleshlight.
You could have drove up in.net
and click on the link for the
flashlight.
You can enter in the name Rogan and get
15 percent off and number one sex toy
from that.
And then you could shoot loads in there
at a discount.
Georgia,
I'm going to give you one before you
leave.
Take it,
throw it in the garbage.
Do whatever you like,
sir.
It is yours.
Georgia is in the house from ancient
aliens.
Eddie Bravo isn't the house red bands in
the house.
Pitches is ready to throw the fuck down.
This is the magic of twitter.
Ladies and gentlemen,
and the Internet.
Just something happened.
I don't remember where we were tweeting
about,
but all of a sudden Georgia tweeted me
back and I tweet him and I say,
you want to do my podcast and says fuck
Ya.
And boom.
And then we meet in Vegas and we're
hanging out in vegas like we'd known
each other forever.
Fucking time.
Thank you dude.
There was a lot of fucking fun man.
Georgia was a cool cat.
And uh,
I mean,
one of my favorite shows of all time,
I love that ancient aliens.
I've got a big stack of them,
like don't necessarily agree with
everything,
but I don't think you do either.
I think it's a lot of,
who knows,
right?
Absolutely.
So a lot of.
I mean that's what I got from you
talking to you in Vegas.
I was like,
man,
maybe that's crazy.
Maybe it's going to Atlanta,
this was a spaceship.
But if you don't know what I mean,
but you were like really open to any
possibility which I truly admire in a
person.
You know?
So many people are married to their
fucking ideas,
even preposterous ideas.
Like,
you know,
the,
David,
I really fucking believes that there's
reptilians that are running this planet,
you know,
like in,
and he says he's got facts and
information.
Motherfucker.
Have you seen a reptilian?
If you haven't,
how can you be sure?
How can you be when you hear stuff like
that?
Now you're in the business of,
of this wild,
crazy.
You have a world where so many people
look down on anything that's even
remotely outside of the mainstream of it
gets ridiculed,
but when you see a guy like David,
right,
do you ever say,
I wonder if this motherfucker works for
the government puts says so much and so
much shit.
That makes sense,
and then he starts talking about
reptilians and he got to go,
well that's classic disinformation.
That's like the move that's like,
you know,
if you want to a piss in the well we
could do is just throw a bunch of shit
in there that really makes sense.
Like the CIA killed JFK and we were in
Vietnam for money and the military
industrial complex.
It really does run things just like
Eisenhower said.
Plus there's a pace on the moon.
We've been donating their telepathically
for years and what we do is we.
We have a place where we go,
well,
we teleport people and you have to be
naked and that's why women aren't
allowed to be on the base.
I know.
What the fuck are you talking about,
man?
And Bright,
thrilling,
all that wacky shit in there.
You're kind of piss on all the stuff
that is interesting because you know,
you could say,
well,
wait a minute,
this guy said that the CIA killed
Kennedy,
but then he also talked about the Wacky
Shit on the moon,
right?
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
I mean,
to me it's very resistant when you go
with your gut feeling because our people
out there really at the same time,
some of this book that you would say
also carry some math so you know,
that's a problem.
Know at the end of the day you just have
to let it go and be like,
that's what those people are not gonna
know anything.
Whenever you have a choice because in
the end we all make a choice what we
believe in,
what we subscribe to and you know,
some of that stuff is crazy.
Guess what I mean?
If you look at the science today,
science book,
you know there are all these different
theories and ideas and it's pretty much
cutting edge on the cutting edge of
knowledge.
But if you look in a textbook from 200
years ago,
which was published by the university,
that was considered cutting edge of
knowledge at the time.
Now you're looking at that textbook
today,
200 years later and 99 percent of
acknowledging obsolete.
Is that true?
Like what has been disproven?
Like what field has been completely
reworked over the last 200 years to
their stuff as stuff gets updated and
how much of it is absolutely.
It all comes down to an edison were
certain procedures that time considered
to be perfect like radiation treatment
that were actually run from the station
on the monitor comes down said about
David.
I have to ask John.
I can totally make.
He was a shell.
It was on youtube,
on a Michelle,
and now they're friends and they're
going to be gone each other to hang out
with Alex at one weekend in Vegas
because you're a big Alex Jones Fan.
Listen brother,
I love Alex too.
I love Alex to.
Come on.
Let's hang out with the dude and then
you get a better sense of what else
counts.
Stones is Alex Jones,
24 slash seven,
whether it's a fucking conspiracy to
keep him from getting a cigarette.
She tried to keep it from that.
Beer was this woman who works at the
bar.
He sees me,
he avoids me,
avoids contact management.
Keep me from having a parent who's about
the tickets.
Remember the tick everything.
Anything.
I was worried that we weren't really
going to get in the UFC tickets.
My brother,
you're good.
You're my friend.
We're cool.
Keith,
he's a great guy.
He's a great guy,
but he's crazy,
you know,
and you to be crazy to dig for the truth
that much.
And I look,
I say,
but Alex,
he's right about a lot.
Shit,
I don't know what the percentage is.
I always throw out a number like he's
right about 70 percent,
but the 30 percent flexing that he just,
you know,
kind of fills in the blanks.
There's a lot of filling in the blanks,
but the 70 percent that he's,
or whatever number it is that he is
right.
It's worth it.
It's shocking.
And he's a perfect example of what you
were talking about before,
like where you have to Kinda like use
her own filter.
There's a lot of stuff that he says that
has an incredible amount of merit.
It's absolutely correct.
And this stuff that says you're just
going,
what the fuck are you talking about?
He gets crazy.
He doesn't go reptilian crazy,
but he gets deep in new world order.
He gets a like,
like eugenics crazy.
He gets like he's sure they have a
population decreased plan where they're
going to kill off.
Most people except for 500,000
elites were going to be able to live
forever.
And like,
man,
you got to have some fucking rock solid
evidence to throw that one around.
You can't just toss that out like a
beach ball that the elites are gonna.
Kill out fucking have a population
except $500,000.
Maybe be someone's thought that up.
I'm not saying it's outside of the realm
of possibility.
Your business though is filled with
that.
They mean,
look,
there are hundreds of billions of stars
in this galaxy and we have already
spotted so many of them over the last
couple of decades or a couple of years
rather,
that are in the goldilocks zone where
they know kid possibly inhabit life.
They sprouted visit.
I don't know what the number are,
orbiting increases all the time.
They're constantly finding planets that
could possibly support.
Right.
And planets that are older than ours by
a billion years plus or.
Absolutely.
In.
The fascinating thing is that,
you know,
when the sixties and seventies,
when Erich von Daniken first wrote,
chariots of the Gods,
you know,
the general consensus in the sixties and
seventies was that this discussion was
even more taboo than it is today
obviously.
But back then,
you know,
it was like,
maybe we were alone in the universe and
there was only a handful like Frank
Drake and the Carl Sagan who proposed
the idea or dabbled with the idea that,
you know,
we might not be the only ones in the
mainstream.
Legitimate.
Exactly.
I'm a community now today.
You,
you'd be hard pressed to find any
scientist or any astronomer or
astrophysicist that will tell you that
they think we're alone in the universe.
So we've definitely switched where it's
almost a given now that,
uh,
everyone thinks that,
you know,
they're intelligent life exists in the
universe.
However,
the big taboo topic that we have today
that still remains is okay,
they'll say there is life in the
universe,
in the galaxy,
but there is no way that that
intelligent life could have ever been
here or visited birth in the remote past
or even present day.
And that to me is a fallacy in logic
because granted the distances between
the stars are indeed huge too mind
boggling.
But just because we can't get from point
a to point b doesn't mean another
society that like you mentioned where
you sit or inferred that there are
bullying years older than us on third
world at least as a billion years old.
Well,
I mean we are a very,
very young culture by any means of the
imagination.
So someone that's only 100,000
years older,
I mean they have technologies or other
type of.
Something where they combine biology
with technology and things like that
that we couldn't even dream up right
now.
Our imagination is the only thing that
limits us from seeing what they could
possibly have given them a thousand
years in advance of us in a million
years or even a few hundred years.
Man,
look what Nikola Tesla was doing in the
early 20th century and,
and,
and look at what's going on today.
I mean,
that's a gigantic monumental leap and
just a little over 100 years.
That's amazing.
Well,
I mean,
just imagine showing your great grandpa
one of our phones today.
Yeah.
I mean to,
to him and star Trek couldn't fuck with
that.
Right,
exactly.
They thought you were going to be able
to beam people onto a planet,
but they still had walkie talkies
cookout.
You know,
he fucking,
he didn't think.
Couldn't wrap
their head around the idea that you
would have real time communication on
that states.
I convene people there,
but you can't have,
you know,
you can just talk into it.
The voice thing.
Depressed the voice thing.
Go Eddie Bravo,
bravo comes wikipedia page videos.
That's fucking amazing and it's even
with three,
14 years fast as fuck,
man,
any alien species that's a thousand
years from last night,
we're going to know what they can do is
absolutely silly.
We already understand principles of
folding space time and meeting those two
points and having a gateway to something
they know that the possibility that's
existing in the unit,
completely theoretical,
but so many things were theoretical just
a couple of hundred years ago and look
what they're doing right now with with
this higgs Boson collider in that the
move on plasma,
but part of freedom,
one sugar camp is 40 or $440.
Billion tons I think.
Which one?
Either one fucking great sugar cube,
you know,
and the fact that they're gonna come up,
they're,
they're hinting that they're really
close to discovering the God particle.
This is Boston us today in 2011
something a thousand years from now.
My thought is always though that why
would we even see it?
They could come as clouds.
You don't think they're gonna be able to
disguise themselves as a fucking tree or
just not.
Not Be visible at a around us right now
and that is the same allegory and
sometimes uses if you have some patio
lighting out on your patio and you have
a cat and that cat loves to go outside
in the patio every night and you look up
to the sky or look up to the patio
lights,
sees the lights and the cat might think,
yeah,
this is very pretty.
It's beautiful,
but that cat has no concept of what goes
into those patio lights,
that there's electricity,
plastic wiring,
all these different things.
But so,
which means that,
that is exactly the concept of exit
terrestrials as well,
that they can conceivably show up as
some type of shape shifters or something
and not just into people but into
objects or something because they would
use exactly the same what we use today.
And that's technology,
but there's something involved where,
you know,
just because we can't figure it out
doesn't mean it does not exist.
I always say I always bring up what I
call the art theory when it comes to,
uh,
to aliens.
And my theory is that the idea is that
if you couldn't smell,
if you didn't have a sense of smell,
you would have no idea that farts
existed.
You had no idea that you were just
sitting in someone's asked gas,
right?
You would have no,
no clue,
but because you have a sense of smell,
this invisible thing all of a sudden
becomes a reality.
How do we not know there are a million
different senses,
a million different things that are
around us all the time that we just
can't tune into an all some alien has to
do is tune into something that's outside
of our spectrum to it,
into something that's not within our
natural ability to perceive.
I mean our natural ability perceive as
very similar to the people that live
10,000
years ago and we're throwing fucking
pointed sticks it,
moving animals.
This is a very,
very little difference between us
genetically now and then.
So how do we not know that the systems
that we have in place are all in place
for the natural world,
all in place for you.
You hear animals,
you know you,
you see moving things you know and you
smelled food.
You know these are all in place to keep
us alive and keep us successful.
We could very well be developing new
senses because of Wifi and because of
all these cellular signals and the way
human beings.
How sick are you right now,
buddy?
You want to go home or you that sick?
They want to go home.
I don't want you to get everybody else
cold.
Perfect example.
It's fucking some shit flying through
the air in this room right now.
That's this guy's sick and he's got some
germs inside of his body.
There's some shit that you can't see
unless you get a microscope and they're
little invading animals.
They're trying to take over and kill
him.
So his army right now is at war.
There's so much shit out there.
There's so much shit out there that we
can't wrap our heads around because it's
happening right here at this table right
now.
There's aliens watching us in the
fridge.
You get into your field and how did you
get on ancient aliens?
Well,
for that,
I really have to thank my,
my grandma because growing up I,
I traveled around the world with my,
with my parents and they made sure that
we would go to those different museums
and archeological sites and things like
that.
Then,
you know,
have like guided tours by the resident
archeologists or the resident curator
and stuff like that.
Um,
but then whenever I would come back
home,
my grandma would say,
all right,
so you've just been taught about the
contemporary contemporary ideas of
particular cultures,
but let me show you that other ideas and
theories exist as well.
So she would tell me about that.
Lantus,
she would tell me about,
you know,
the ancient astronauts theory and
chariots of the gods and all those
different viewpoints that have been
proposed by others.
So for me,
these types of topics have been.
I've been exposed to those fairly,
at a fairly young age.
I mean this was all dinner table
conversation.
Um,
especially,
you know,
when my parents or my grandparents would
visit a.
But at the same time,
my mom,
she always used to say that whenever we
would have to use this discussion,
she would say,
you know,
I really think that all of this that we
have today,
it's been here before.
And I never knew what she meant.
And of course,
you know,
I was five,
six,
seven years old,
but today I knew exactly.
And I finally understand what she meant
that,
you know,
this is just a repetition of history.
How high was she when she started this?
Hey,
I was,
I was too young.
So I'm sure they're talking about
civilization.
I don't think so.
Not My mom.
No,
she is,
she's lovely.
And all of them that right now.
And um,
you know,
so,
so the,
the question,
you know,
so today especially,
now that my parents were like,
you know,
for,
for a long time,
they with that guy,
you're wasting your time with this,
Yada Yada.
And uh,
now all I have to say is that,
you know,
I am here because of my parents and my
grandparents.
And so it's,
it's,
it was their fault that all this
happened.
What year did chariots of the gods came
out?
It came out like in the sixties.
Yeah,
it was first published in German under
the title memories of the future in 1968
and then it was a runaway success and
the first English edition came out in
1970 and within a,
you know,
eight months or so,
6 million copies have been sold.
I mean it was an absolute phenomenon
that they called the keitus and he was a
huge success worldwide and here we are
in 2011 in chariots of the Gods is still
read Eric Fund.
Danny can just turned 77 years old by
the way.
He says hello to the entire audience.
He's very happy and excited that I'm
under program.
So he says yes,
absolutely listening.
So we're trying.
We're trying to get him on the program
to bring them in.
We'll do it.
Remote sensing.
Where does he live?
He lives in Switzerland.
I'll fucking fly out to switch.
All right,
well we'll definitely set something up.
I love it when you first met him.
It's that kind of crazy.
Really.
I would say it was weird the first time
we actually hung out and had a
conversation and stuff because I had,
you know,
I had gone to some of his lectures when
I was in my early teens.
So you know,
and you know,
it's different than someone named
forever.
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
look,
I started the magazine that are
published.
You published legendary 1998.
That's when we started in 1998 and in
legendary times is basically all about
ancient civilizations.
Yes.
And it's specifically geared towards
ancient civilizations in respect to the
ancient astronaut theory suggesting or
exploring the idea whether or not extra
terrestrials flesh and blood exits.
Terrestrials visited earth in the remote
past.
And by that I don't mean you know,
a hundred years ago,
but we're talking five,
six,
seven,
8,000
years ago from today.
When you look at it,
when you look at the Sumerian texts and
you look at funding Akins work and what
is your gut impression?
Would you an thank you if got not making
a conclusion.
Which way do you lean?
Do you mean 50 percent that they were.
They were here 50 percent than maybe
something else happened.
Like what?
How do you?
More than 50 percent personally?
Yes.
One hundred percent.
Absolutely.
It gives you the most hope or the most a
reason to believe this.
Well,
because it's I,
I sometimes liken it to when you're
completing a puzzle,
it doesn't matter how big the puzzle is,
but the more pieces you put together,
the more pieces you fit into place,
even when that puzzle is not yet
completed.
And we've all done puzzles as kids,
it gets easier as you move along,
but you can stop somewhere three
quarters of the way and you can look at
that puzzle and you know exactly what
the picture looks like even though it's
not yet complete.
And there's a couple of pieces missing.
So that is what the ancient astronauts
theory to me is like that there are so
many indications from our ancient
cultures that the conclusion,
in my opinion is inescapable.
And I'm not just saying this,
you know,
because I'm pulling this out of my ass,
but because there are stories and there
are physical pieces of evidence that the
only conclusion that we can draw unless
we go into the realm of the fantastical
and the unlikely is that we have been
visited by flesh and blood exits the
restaurant.
What is the,
what is like,
if you were going to try to convince
somebody,
what is the most compelling evidence in
your opinion that,
you know,
you said there's,
there's evidence where you cannot draw
any other conclusions.
What is the most compelling?
Well,
you know,
and this is where I truly enjoy and
respect the work of many archaeologists
around the world because they excavating
a different,
uh,
sites and different monuments and
they're truly breaking their backs for
some fantastic research.
However,
sometimes when you look at that research
or some of the ideas that they present,
um,
there are some faults in,
in,
in logic there because they,
for example,
suggests that we have moved a block
that's 1,500
tons heavy,
1,500
metric tons heavy with a piece of string
and some chicken bones.
And today our cranes,
they tap out at 1,350
tons.
So if we today,
how much difference is that weight was.
Oh,
that's,
we're talking about 200 and 200 tons.
So 200 tons shy.
Yeah,
we can do to.
Right,
right,
exactly.
It's heavier.
So using that as the best proof.
Well,
I mean there's multiple.
I mean that,
that one block for example,
is it the city in Lebanon called bow
back?
I've seen,
we've all seen that amazing stone that's
in charge of the God the movie.
Exactly,
yes.
Heliopolis,
you've seen it already right beyond you,
you,
you can't even wrap your head around it.
He was like,
this is not,
you can't move this,
move this.
So you have photos of that.
Was it maybe just something that we're
not thinking of like,
like it was,
you know,
underwater at one point it made it
easier to move rocks or anything like
that or this,
it doesn't make it easier to move
something to epic.
What would the,
the,
the possibilities are?
There's two in my opinion,
there's his idea that we've been visited
by ancient aliens and then there's the,
the idea that civilization has been
restarted several times and that is that
there's some sort of a cataclysmic event
that's killed almost everybody except
for a small amount of stragglers and
they regrouped and rebuilt and rethought
things out.
And that's one of the reasons why things
come so quickly and technology is moving
so fast and as your mom said,
or whose grandmother,
whoever it was,
that we are relearning.
We've done this before.
And,
and it can also be a combination of
both.
You see that?
That's the thing that uh,
there are.
Can I see that picture?
Of course.
This is the one.
This is the,
this is Baalbek.
Yes.
There's the bow back.
It's called the stone of the pregnant
woman and it's one of the biggest
monoliths that has ever been seen on
planet earth.
And uh,
you know,
to me right there,
we could not move this with our modern
day cranes.
And so,
you know,
something happened in all of the ancient
sites because you know,
we know there's absolutely no question
in my mind that our ancestors,
I mean they were extremely smart.
They were ingenious and obviously did
they know how to cut stones and how to
transport them and things like that.
However,
there,
and I'm not really interested in moving
around stones that are cut from
limestone or sandstone and things like
this.
But what I'm interested in is stuff like
this where it was cut out of granted or
out of diorite.
We're still today.
We use diamond tip saws in order to cut
any of these blocks that we cut today
and allegedly our ancestors that this
with copper tools.
And I'm sorry,
somewhere the logic just fails because
there's logic certainly fails that,
that technology that we attributed to
those people because we have to put them
in the bronze age.
And the copper age,
we can't put them in the age of steel,
but to me the logic is much more likely
that they we were wrong about the age of
bronze and steel and that people had to
figure it out.
Diverse hip tools like went there,
didn't they find markings inside the
sarcophagus and the king's chamber of
the Great Pyramid of Giza?
Yes.
That they believe were attributed only
to diamond.
Head of drill.
Absolutely.
And in Egypt we have a very fascinating
site called Abi Dose and in Abi Dose you
have a sorry,
in Aba Zeer,
not in Dose Abbott doses where they have
to do those weird hieroglyphics,
but in Ab Azir you have a what's known
as a signatures of core drills,
and a core drill is basically if you
imagine a steel tube tip with diamonds
that drills itself into the ground or
into the Rock,
and then you break it free.
You take out that tube and inside of it
you have like a pipe of that,
a cordial sample of that particular
rock.
Now in Abu Azir,
we find multiple stones where we can see
a signature of these types of machining
that took place there.
Now a lot of people have said,
oh,
well,
these are all modern day occurrences.
And uh,
it was done.
You know,
when the first first a modern day core
drill machine was invented in 19,
early 19 twenties.
Now when you look at the book that Surf
Flinders Petrie wrote,
that book was written in Nineteen Oh
six.
And it already had drawings of those
core drill holes in them,
which proves that these core drill holes
that we can find acquisitions are not
modern day creations.
And that is absolutely crazy because
Christopher done,
one of my colleagues who wrote the Giza
power plant,
he proved because he's a machinist,
I mean he's an engineer and he knows
this stuff like the back of his hand.
So it's not like somebody walked along
and said,
this is how it is.
But this guy,
that's what he does for a living.
He builds machines and he,
uh,
you know,
precision mechanisms and things like
this.
So he is trained for that kind of a,
you know,
investigation and uh,
he said that there is no way that this
could have been done with,
uh,
with copper tools.
I mean,
it's just.
And so,
you know,
there's some,
just wild,
wild pieces of evidence that we have out
there like in Puma Puma,
for example,
highly in the Bolivian highlands at an
altitude of 12 and a half thousand feet.
There is this magnificent place called
to an ACO that everyday hundreds of
tourists arrive there and they look at
it,
it take pictures and then they leave as
clueless as they arrived.
And,
um,
uh,
about 150 200 yards away from,
from,
to knock who there's another site that's
very much lesser known,
called Puma Puma.
Cool.
And at Puma Puma,
everything defies logic is defied at
Puma.
Puma will be caused the blocks of stone
that we have.
There are pure diorite,
andesite and granted and uh,
they are so perfect that we today would
have a hard time recreating some of
these blocks.
And I actually spoke to a real life
stonemasons.
His name is Roger Hopkins.
And he looked at some of these pictures
that I showed him of Puma Puma crew,
and he said that not for any amount of
money or for any amount of time would
volunteer to try to replicate some of
these rocks as somebody blocks.
And if a real life stone mason says
this,
I mean God bless the,
um,
the professors and the archeologists,
but I'd rather listen to someone who cut
stone for a living than someone you know
who stands before a blackboard.
But this guy who cut stone for a living,
what he said was that it could be done.
You said it would be really hard and he
wouldn't want to do it for any amount of
money,
but that it couldn't be done.
Yes.
But I wouldn't lead with,
with modern day.
Yes.
And not with what?
So with chicken bones,
if we know that if we know that it could
be done with modern technology,
wouldn't it be more likely that modern
technology is sort of a recreation of
what people did learn in the past and
that they probably were wiped out by
some sort of a cataclysmic disaster.
That to me,
seems way more likely than aliens came
and moved rocks.
No,
you're saying if like if Pete,
if it'd be really,
really difficult for people to do it
today.
Well,
there's a lot of stuff that will be
incredibly difficult for people to do it
today.
I'm not necessarily suggesting
suggesting that aliens moved to rocks.
What I'm saying is that the aliens that
visited Earth gave the technology or
taught the technology to humans because
what they wanted to do is to leave
behind messages that they were here in
the past.
So all those incredible monuments that
we have today,
like the Pyramids of Giza or Stonehenge
or Puma Puma for example,
or new grange.
All these magnificent sights in Cusco,
Machu Picchu in Peru,
that all those places are messages for a
future generation to understand that
something way different happened in our
past.
That is the main reason why,
for example,
we have religions today and things like
this.
So.
So you think that pretty much all
science emanates from some sort of an
alien contact?
Is that what you think?
Uh,
no because modern day,
because you know,
because was a trace of modernist science
so you can follow it.
Exactly right.
Now let's think about this.
What,
what age do you think people had
technology that sort of any fucking nut
that crashed and the,
you know,
the TV show lost crash on an island and
you could recreate,
what was that like maybe 2000,
3000 years ago,
no more thousand dollars,
something like that.
So like five,
6,000
years ago they were basically living
like savages,
right?
Supposedly.
Suppose serially supposedly yes.
If you follow,
let's give him even even even early.
I mean,
look,
the thing is my point,
I'm sorry,
I just,
my point was that if in 10,000
years time people have gone from being
cave dwelling savages that were throwing
pointy sticks,
it,
moving animals to people with cell
phones and the Internet and wireless and
this is all created pain arguably by
human beings.
There's a record of all these inventions
and all these creations.
If this has been achieved over 10,000
years,
what's to say that there wasn't some
sort of a massive disaster that happened
at the end of the last ice age or
younger in in their 20,000
years ago,
but the date it for 15,000,
whatever the fuck it is,
and that technology died and that
civilization died and it had to be
reinvented by the surviving humans
basically from scratch and that even
though human beings have been around for
a long,
long,
long time before that and civilization
had evolved to an incredibly high level,
all that information was lost.
That to me is way more likely than
aliens.
Well,
but see,
here's the thing.
This is where the difference lies that
when let's say the Sumerian culture
sprung out of virtually nothing happened
virtually overnight.
The Sumerians were very clear in stating
that they got their start in
civilization by what they referred to as
the under knocking and the unlock key
translated into English means those who
from the hurricane.
Yes,
exactly,
but isn't that true that that's only by.
That means Zechariah stitching is pretty
much the main scholar of the Sumerian
texts that police.
There's a lot of other scholars that do
not agree with it.
Absolutely.
But the translation,
even a,
a,
a quote unquote mainstream scientist or
some neurologist will say that on
knocking means that I mean that,
that is not,
for example,
the sicker,
right.
He did have quite a few things that he
translated,
you know,
quote unquote himself.
Uh,
so that's definitely a valid point.
But there are the great majority of what
he's
talking about has been translated
correctly and he has used,
you know,
many of the most accessible,
uh,
and correct translations that can be
found today.
But even in the epic of Gilgamesh,
don't they refer to a long gone superior
civilization that existed before then?
Yes.
But that,
but that civilization always lived,
quote unquote somewhere else and
integrate dark void.
Now what's the great dark avoid?
That's a beautiful Pasadena city name.
It's a poetic way of saying compton deep
space.
Compton would've been better for him.
Shit fucked up.
Yeah,
maybe.
Maybe it is,
but you know,
you follow me.
What I'm saying is that like,
you know,
I firmly believe that there's life out
there.
I mean,
I think the possibility is,
you know,
there's the numbers,
and I think it's also very possible that
it's reached us,
but I think if you look at what's more
likely,
if we absolutely know that people can
build a immense structures,
if we absolutely know that civilization,
uh,
most likely because of all these
historical,
you know,
depictions of natural disasters,
whether it's the epic of Gilgamesh or
Noah's Ark,
or 100 different cultures that have
stores of apocalyptic disastrous and the
volatile nature of the earth itself.
The fact that we know it's covered in
craters,
the fact that we know that every plan
and we look at the moon and just see
creators all over the place.
We know about the shifting of the polar
ice caps,
who know about Pangea.
We know that there was intelligent life
probably in some sort of a monkey forum
when Pangea was around,
right?
Yes.
No,
absolutely.
But a beating for people don't know the
whole entire world is one continent
that's a fieriness drifted apart.
I think that,
I mean,
I just think that if we know for a fact
that human beings are capable now of
doing spectacular things,
and we have said already that if we
existed 100 years more man,
and imagine what we would know.
Just imagine what has sprung out over
the last hundred,
300 years.
You know,
and I think you add a few hundred years
for that or a thousand years to that.
It's not unreasonable in my opinion,
to think that 10,000
years ago there was some sort of an
event,
some sort of catastrophic.
Maybe it's $15,000,
whatever the fuck name it,
a catastrophic event that fuck this
world sideways and killed almost
everybody.
To me that is just way more likely than
these people got it from some higher
intelligence.
Both of them.
A Combo of both.
And how many different ancient
civilizations tell you,
tell the people where they got their,
their knowledge.
It's not just the Samaritans,
they're all telling you there's an
incredible monuments that were puzzled
us today.
We're telling you that dudes from Earth,
from the heavens came down and showed
us,
but no one's bleeding.
We're also telling you that a guy died
and came back to earth three days later
he turned water into
wine.
But these,
these are structures that actually you
could see in their scientists.
Baffled by what you mean,
like structures and stuff in South
America,
the Mayans.
Um,
all the ancient Sumerian.
Well,
yeah.
the,
the Mayans,
you know,
they did their shit is totally
different.
I mean they believe that a fucking plume
snake created the universe.
No,
hold on a second now.
That's exactly what I'm talking about.
What?
What is behind this story?
Snake mushrooms like a motherfucker in
the jungle.
Hang it out.
Banging hot.
My in checks chilling.
I mean that.
No Internet.
That's definitely an idea and
possibility playing football with human
heads.
But I'm trying to figure out what are
the realities behind the stories.
I certainly think it's a possibility.
I'm not ruling out that pause.
Oh no,
of course not.
But you know,
it is definitely a combination because
the bottom line is that all these
ancient cultures are very adamant and
very specific in saying that this all
happened because of a visit from beings
from the stars.
The star thing is very prevalent.
If it were a previous civilization or if
it were,
let's say,
human beings.
Because sometimes people say,
well,
how come you don't?
How come you're not talking about that?
Maybe a w.
it's our civilization from the future
travel into the past to help us with
certain developments.
Well,
that can't be true because nowhere in
the ancient texts do we find any
reference where it says,
well,
we're just like you,
but we're from the future.
Maybe future bullshit artists.
That's those little gray dudes.
Are they just completely full of Shit?
They're us from the future,
but they fuck with us the same way we
fuck with monkeys.
If you,
if you get in the cage,
I'll give you a banana and the monkey
gets in the cage and you just steal
them.
Take them to the zoo,
given that banana.
And he was like,
what?
The crazy thing about Zachariah,
essentially when people questioned his
translations are the things that he got
right in the seventies and they were
finding out just today in 2000,
one,
2002,
that in the stories that he's talking
about,
the adult hockey,
he saying in a nutshell that there's a
hyper advanced wraith is created us as
slaves to mine gold because they needed
gold dust particles to suspend them.
An atmosphere to protect our planet.
Well,
we just discovered in the 2000 thing,
hey,
you actually do protect atmospheres by
suspending metallic product.
How the hell did an archeologist know
some astrophysics in the seventies?
That's an intention.
Yeah.
Well it is possible that they were
really sophisticated seven,
8,000
years ago and they knew that we were
eventually going to run into the same
problems again.
I mean they,
maybe they were burning shit back then
that was eating up the ozone layer.
Maybe they were fucking with chemicals
back then just like we are now.
But that.
So that would mean that were super
smart.
Yeah.
But they're telling you specifically
the reason why they to.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well,
they figured it out,
figured it out,
just like we figured it out now and they
figured it out then.
No,
but they're telling you how they figured
it out.
They're saying they're saying they got
it from the owner.
Not Again,
this.
I don't know.
See,
I don't know enough about language to
argue against or for switching,
but I know that he's a road scholar.
He's not the only one though.
I mean again,
knockier to Sumerian stories are not the
only stories that we find constraints
for evidence Dogan mean they completely
such detailed astronomical knowledge
which was not corroborated it until the
19,
early 19 sixties and there's still
people that say,
oh,
this is a complete hoax when it really
isn't.
I mean they knew about invisible stars
that were then later truly corroborated
by NASA and other astrophysicists.
I mean,
how on earth would they know something
like this and the Dogan give you the
answers that they were visited by
somebody that descended from the sky and
then who are we to say that these people
are lying or that they made up fantasy
stories because that to me is the
insult,
right?
When people,
we'll say salt the fuck out of some old
tribes.
Shit.
No,
no,
no snakes.
I'm just referring to,
you know,
because because people archeologist the
bunkers are saying,
well,
you know,
you,
you guys attribute everything to alien
intervention and uh,
you know,
you undermine to human,
human ingenuity.
You're suggesting that,
you know,
our ancestors were stupid and,
and nothing could be further from the
truth because obviously nothing happened
in our brain development in the last
50,000
years.
If you bring someone from 10,000
years ago to today,
you can teach that person how to drive a
car.
You can teach that person even to fly a
plane,
no problem.
Because intellectually speaking they're
as capable as we are today.
However,
there was one huge difference and that
is their technological frame of
reference was different or smaller than
what we have today.
So when we have stories of flying
shields or dragons or smoking a snakes
and plumes and plume snakes and things
like that,
then my question is,
well,
what was it exactly that our ancestors
try to describe with their vocabulary
because they didn't have the vocabulary
for rocket or for,
you know,
so they had to liken a rocket to a
blazing oven or something like this or
you know,
gleaming bronze,
a monster and things like that.
So there in lies,
lies the big difference.
And so when archeologists and say,
well,
you know,
you're saying that I undermine human
ingenuity from the past.
It's like,
no,
I'm really not because I am reading to
you exactly that these same people said
that they received their knowledge from
these humanoid beings that the senate
from the sky.
So you think that that's the,
uh,
the most compelling piece of evidence to
you is a human beings depictions of what
was going on,
like given us or you know.
No,
no,
that is definitely.
See that,
and that's the great thing about the
ancient alien theory that you can,
you know,
it's such an interdisciplinary field of
research that,
you know,
you can look at ancient Egypt and you
can look at South America and draw
correlations.
I mean they did.
They found crazy correlations between
those two cultures,
for example,
where they found cocaine in mummies and
things like that where cocaine was only
available in one country.
And so,
so it was definitely,
I mean,
something definitely happened that there
was trade between continents and
personally I suggest that trait didn't
necessarily happen on,
on water,
but that they actually had,
you know,
aircraft because that is what the
ancient texts are saying,
not only in India with the vimanas but
also in,
um,
in the Hebrew and an Ethiopian cultures.
Have you have the story of King Solomon
and his flying carpet and it's flying
machine.
Didn't your show take an artifact and
recreated?
Explain that.
Tell me about what happened there.
Well,
where was the artifact from?
It's from South America,
from Columbia,
and it's a gold funerary objects.
It's a totem that hundreds of thousands
and thousands of those little artifacts
have been found and they will usually
shaped in the form of frogs and insects
and fish and crocodiles and things like
that.
However,
out of those thousands of funerary
objects that have been found about eight
were found worldwide that looked like
modern day airplanes and so these two
engineers in one,
one doctor and one engineer in Germany,
what they did is in the early,
in the mid nineties,
1996,
they took one of those little funerary
objects and they blew it up to ratio and
to size without adding an inch or
subtracting an inch.
I mean they just basically blew it up to
about three to four feet long and it
looks exactly like exactly.
And the.
They put a propeller inside and they had
tried multiple objects.
I mean,
they didn't just do one that they
thought,
well,
this one is most likely like a looks
most likely like a plane,
so let's just do this.
Well No,
they took a whole bunch of them and they
recreated them as,
as model planes.
A throw them up in the air and they were
100 percent aerodynamically sound.
They were able to do roles and looping
loops and stuff like that.
I mean,
they were 100 percent,
uh,
you know,
there were airplanes and even to the
untrained eye,
uh,
they,
they look like planes because here's the
thing that you know,
a lot of people say about when they say
that these are also fish or insects,
but you look at that,
that's an airplane because first of all
it's got a delta shape and a fuselage
and then you have the stabilizers in the
back and you've got an upright rudder
and no living creature in nature does
not exist.
Plus the wing formation is a low wing
formation.
Where would have wings are attached to
the bottom of the fuselage body.
Exactly.
And we have our wings are arms attached
like a,
the birds and the shoulder girdle.
And that formation that we can find in
the Colombian artifact does not.
It doesn't.
It doesn't suggest how old is that
artifact?
One thousand 500 to 1000,
600 years old.
God Dang.
Yeah.
So totally.
My region in Columbia and Pre-colombian
artifact and it's uh,
you know,
so those are all those little things
that all fit together.
Some how,
and in my opinion,
they had something to do with flesh and
blood aliens who visited in the remote
past.
It's so weird that our history is so
incomplete.
That's why we're having this debate.
The reason why we're having this debate
is because we know that the history so
sketchy when you get just a few thousand
years ago,
that's all he fucking knows,
man.
And it doesn't help when you get these
conventional archaeologists that are so
fucking set in their ways.
Man,
this Robert Schoch,
John Anthony West thing that's going on
in Egypt,
in,
pertaining to the dating of the Sphinx.
I find their research fascinating.
What I find more fascinating is how
these mainstream egyptologist just just
poo poo it.
Like,
oh,
well where's the evidence for this
culture?
Like the,
the argument they had was so childish.
It was so egotistical that guy was
standing up going,
you know,
you're talking about the Sphinx being
predating,
you know,
9,000
BC.
Where's the evidence of this culture
that's willing to do?
Where's the evidence?
Like,
what the fuck do you think is going to
be there,
sir?
What do you think is going to be there
after 11,000
years?
You're talking 9,000
BC.
How much is going to be left?
Man,
I'll tell you what's going to be left
rocks and there's your evidence
geological ropps that are so fucked up
by water that it has to be thousands of
years of rainfall,
you know that is unanimous.
When geologists look at the Sphinx
enclosure and they and they show of
photographs of the water,
the water erosion of the fishers,
they're 100 percent agreed that it's
water erosion due to thousands of years
of rain fall by the way rainfall to not
just flooding,
not like one crazy flood know thousands
or many years,
so that just shows you.
It has to be older than 9,000
bc because that was the last time there
was flooding or there's a rain forest in
the Nile Valley know.
And the crazy thing is also that their
research is corroborated by other
research as well.
When my colleague Robert Boulevard came
out with the Orion mystery and when he
suggested that if you look at the great,
the three great pyramids of Giza from a
bird's eye perspective,
you see that the three are sort of lined
up but not completely.
They're not in a straight line.
At the smallest pyramid is a bit off and
he's like,
well that's really strange,
so what's going on here?
And then he determined that these three
pyramids are in fact built to the exact
ratio of Orion to three stars in Orion's
belt.
The band heard though,
that the only way you could see the
three stars from that angle,
you would have to look at everything
upside down from like like that.
It doesn't actually work that way,
but it was disproven that you can you.
You can see it that way,
but not from Earth,
not from.
Not from the way we look at it.
You would have to have reverse
everything.
Is that true?
Yes.
I mean look at the general idea still
holds.
Even though that the upside down theory
is possibly correct.
I am not sure of that,
to be honest with you.
I'm not sure what either I a video.
I think however,
what he did determine is the fact that
the time,
if you were to put three floodlights on
top of each tip of the pyramid and a
fire it straight into the sky,
you know,
like at the bookstore in Las Vegas,
the big been the time when the three
tips of those pyramids would line up
exactly with Orion spelled and you have
software for this where you can rewind
back the night sky and the computer
these days.
Um,
it would be in 12,500,
12,000,
500 years ago,
which bore a labeled or is known
Egyptology as the golden age when the
gods still walked amongst men.
And so the fact that the pyramid,
I mean the Sphinx also eight to 9,000
BC,
well that's 1200.
That's the golden age that everybody
talks about in,
in,
in Egypt,
and really learned thousand BC thousands
of years earlier.
It has to exist because of the thousands
of years of rainfall.
So you are talking,
it'd be 10,500
BC,
maybe 11 or so.
The fact is that the,
and there are ancient texts that talk
about these,
uh,
these,
um,
these previous cultures or your
previous,
uh,
periods of other kings and that lived in
the Egyptian,
a region,
but they're considered to be fantasy
stories by archeologists.
The Pharaohs just like 34,000
years ago,
aren't there?
I mean,
I believe John Anthony West has stated
that he goes back almost 30,000
or more years.
There is a,
there is a king's list out there and
everybody can go google this tonight.
It's called WB 44.
And that kings list absolutely will
boggle your mind because it basically
lists a combined age of kings that ruled
for a half a million years before our
culture.
Now it's absolutely,
it's absolutely crazy.
And so,
and that is a list that can be found at
the British Museum in England,
in London.
Where's it from?
It's from some area and the WB 44.
And it lists for how long,
how long,
how old?
For hundreds of thousands of years.
And some of these kings,
it says,
I have root for 16,000
years for 48,000
years,
one day,
one king.
And then the question is,
well,
how is this even possible that operate
the great type shit that were working
that back then,
man?
Or they are,
we're talking about time,
dilation,
time,
dilation.
If you travel at close to the speed of
light,
if on your spaceship,
five years pass and you travel at 99
point nine percent of the speed of
light,
5,000
years pass here on earth.
And that's just the theory of
relativity,
which is uh,
you know,
and it takes a time,
dilation into account.
I mean,
like anyone that flies a lot,
those people are actually aging slower
than the rest of us.
So the more you are in motion,
the slower you age.
And so this is a mathematically viable
and proven theory that if you travel
clothes,
which,
which of course we,
we are not capable of doing it.
But just because we human beings can't
do it doesn't mean it does not exist.
And that's the big,
you know,
arc is dude would like come down here,
fuck some shit and go yo,
I'll be right back.
Then it comes back like 16,000
years because to him it's only a year.
Yep,
exactly.
It goes to the speed of light or
whatever the hell he goes.
And he comes back.
Yes.
And it sounds like science fiction.
But who says that?
That is not possible.
That's an interesting way to stay valid.
It just say,
listen bitch,
I am coming back and then you actually
do come back and don't.
And those are the stories that we find
that these,
quote unquote gods,
which by the way,
they never existed.
It's all lower case g,
there is no such thing as God's.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's completely,
uh,
it was a complete misunderstanding,
a misinterpretation of our ancestors who
didn't understand the nuts and bolts
technologies behind these visits.
And so they started to worship these
people and those visitors knew exactly
that they were being worshiped because
you know,
it will be the same thing that if we
arrive on a planet one day in the
future,
$5,000
or whatever years from now and we find a
quote unquote intelligent species,
but they're a bit primitive.
Yeah,
well,
you know,
we'll push them a little bit in the
right direction,
show them how to,
you know,
to complete agriculture and medicine and
architecture and all those things.
And then we'll just say,
okay,
we're,
we're gonna disappear again.
Well guess what?
Our once real visit will turn into will
enter the realm of mythology a thousand
or 2000 years after our visit.
And so one day all of us,
all human beings will become ancient
astronauts on some other planets.
It's just,
it's just the eternal.
We'll have a question of,
you're a master of ancient cultures.
Most ancient culture to get,
get up,
get up close to the engine cultures,
have some kind of 2012 a warning or a
signifies the end of some age.
Or what do you think,
you know,
I,
uh,
you know,
I really need you to pay attention to
this because I think that the biggest
threat that we face on December 22nd
2012 is the massive hangover will all be
suffering.
So that's about it because a lot of 2012
stuff with a Zacharias of course.
So,
you know,
here's the thing that would message and
think through was gonna,
you know,
even though took a year away,
when we build it,
look,
here's the thing that,
you know,
the whole thing,
in my opinion is nothing else but a
complete.
Um,
it's,
it's a mass hysteria.
Absolutely.
Because now,
yeah,
well,
he,
even,
uh,
he wrote right before or a year before
he died,
he rephrased his,
um,
theory by saying that if,
if,
if at all in the bureau were to return,
it's going to be around 20,
36 or 38 or something changed it.
Absolutely.
Yes.
But you know,
that's neither here nor there because
the bottom line is that the big problem
with 2012 is the fact that it's not even
2011 right now.
That's what nobody talks about,
that you know,
we,
our calendar is wrong because if there's
a couple of arguments that you can make,
and that is,
you know,
if you look at our code and code
history,
we went from one BC,
two,
one add without a year zero,
which means that we are already at least
by one year off.
So it's either 2012 or ready or it's
still 2010.
And then you know,
we don't know whether or not our
calendar.
We also know that Jesus was not born in
the year zero,
but scholars and I'm talking
theologians,
theological scholars now have determined
that Jesus was born between five and
three add.
So right,
they're worn exactly.
So right there,
we've got another five years considering
the fact that we were being told that
our calendar began ticking on the day of
Jesus's birth.
So long story short in the third,
our third argument is also that it isn't
now Berkeley scholars and scholars in
the university in a university in Rome
have determined that in the Middle Ages
when the monks were in charge of
recording our dates and everything like
that,
that they also made a mistake up to five
years.
So the interesting thing is that to make
a long story short that we could be as
far off as 10 years with our current
date and if you take into consideration
when did our calendar really start
ticking?
Was it at the,
at the time when Jesus died or was it at
the time when he was nailed to the
cross?
Who knows these things?
I mean some have suggested that we're
off by 200 years and these are not
people that,
you know,
I'm just pulling this stuff out of their
butts,
but they are scholars at universities
who have studied this stuff.
And so the bottom line is that the whole
2012,
it's nothing else but complete hysteria
and nothing.
Let me repeat.
Absolutely nothing will happen next
year.
Dude,
what you got to talk to Daniel Pinchbeck
because he's written books and he
doesn't agree with you.
That's fine.
He thinks quite so positive and God
bless them and quit.
So creditable,
not come.
Now,
that didn't.
By the way,
by the way,
quizlet.
Corrado was an exit terrestrial
spaceship.
Do you think so?
Absolutely.
Didn't they predict that um,
the Mayans pr accurately predicted the
solar lunar eclipses in the future.
So if they predicted that,
how is it possible that we say they
predicted it,
right?
We must be following their timeline.
If following their timeline,
then the must be 2012.
Oh No,
absolutely.
You're right.
But if,
if our calendar from the very beginning
was,
is wrong,
then we are basing our wrong calendar on
their calculation.
Right?
But if we're basing our wrong calendar
on their calculations and it lines up
with what we call 19,
19 with,
we call it 2012,
then shouldn't it be that they got the
lunar eclipses right?
So they got 2012,
right?
No,
they definitely have 2012.
Right?
And by the way,
the deal,
yes,
but not yes in their counting in their
town but not ours.
Yes.
But how is their accounting like line up
exactly with ours when it comes to the
prediction of solar and lunar eclipses
then?
Well,
soon and lunar eclipses it doesn't
matter what you're in.
Right?
But they,
they accurately depicted the year that
the solar and lunar eclipses according
to our talent.
But we impose,
we super imposed.
They're counting onto ours.
So we tried to make it fit.
Yes,
exactly.
Okay.
So you see,
and here's the other thing that's tricky
when you get to calendars to right,
like one a completely different type of
calendar than ours.
And so there must be something happened
and then to December 20,
first 2012,
I must signify at the end of the 13th,
what does that mean?
And that is the long couch and that is
the exact thing that you know,
the Mayans,
not once,
not once did they ever say that the
world was going to end.
The only thing they said is that one
period of time ends and a new period of
time begins.
So it could be that you know,
if you believe,
some people believe that time has a
certain qualities to it,
that there are times when things are
easier and times and things are harder
and that this is literally like an ebb
and flow,
like the tines and that perhaps with the
Mayans were predicting is just some new
stage of humanity,
some new stage of existence,
some new states with the earth and the
universe that this thing just things
just keep flowing in this sort of a
circular direction.
Well,
yeah,
I mean look at everything as we know is,
is cyclical.
So yeah.
So that is definitely in this.
They mastered the procession of the
equinoxes and they had figured that out.
They had figured out a lot of cycles
that would really complex who taught
them this and they're also very true
mushrooms and a lot of free time also.
So the aliens who were dressed up as
little mushroom mascot,
what it is,
what do you say to people that say,
well,
how do we know Jesus really even exist?
They're like dvds and stuff that did was
that DVD,
the God that God wasn't there.
It wasn't that there was a lot of kind
of argue scientifically that he's not a,
not a real figure.
I,
you know,
I personally think that Jesus,
100 percent was a historical figure.
He was an alien.
No,
no,
no.
And,
and neither was Buddha and neither were
any of the other quote unquote
astronaut.
No,
no,
I just think that,
you know,
Jesus was a historical figure,
was able to move people,
but uh,
that,
uh,
he was the son of God,
in my opinion,
is nonsense because we are all the sons
and daughters of God.
We all have the divine within our
hearts.
So what kind of proof,
I mean,
you've studied a lot of ancient
cultures,
obviously.
What do you know of any proof that.
What did Jesus exist exactly?
Well,
I mean,
we've had,
we have stories.
We have texts that have been written
down at the time,
the,
like the Qumran texts to have the Dead
Sea scrolls and things like that.
So,
I mean,
obviously nobody took a picture and the,
you know,
there are some in Texas where you get
real squirrely because the dead sea
scrolls,
that's where it's the trace it back to
an ancient Sumerian where Christ is an
ancient Sumerian word that means a
mushroom covered in God's semen.
Well,
interesting on Marco Allegro Story.
Yes.
Although interestingly enough,
what's also fascinating,
what many people don't know is that
before Jesus,
they were 15 other crucified,
quote unquote saviors in human history.
And so it's all very bizarre that,
uh,
you know,
Christianity claims that he was the only
one which is completely untrue.
And when you measure his story next to
all these other stores,
I mean,
even Hercules,
Hercules and Jesus,
pretty fucking close.
Lot of Goddamn similarities.
You know,
it's,
it's pretty obvious that we've always
been looking for a savior.
I've always been looking for a one,
a one thing.
And I think that's just some Alpha male
chimpanzee thing.
When you look for the Alpha and you
think somehow,
you know,
the one at one point in time there was a
super alpha and the Super Alpha had all
the answers.
Is it just a myth to keep people going?
What does that mean?
What is the need for this,
this Super Alpha?
Do you think that it signifies this
alien intervention in human history?
Is that what you're.
Is that what you personally believe?
No,
I,
I just think that a lot of times people
are not happy with their own thoughts
that they need to,
but this Athena,
one time,
there was a god.
The theme exists in all of them.
All of the different religions all talk
about one point in time there was a god
and this God had all the answers.
This is the shit that he wrote down,
but this is the shit that he told me.
Here's the thing that you know,
I mean,
uh,
if you want to look at the Old Testament
where we have a description of quote
unquote God in the ancient astronaut
opinion,
whatever or whoever with described in
the Old Testament,
and this is exclusively referring to the
Old Testament,
has nothing to do with you'll shit.
Yes.
That whatever or whoever was described
in the old testament by all means was
not God.
That being or that humanoid x,
uh,
a creature that was here was
misinterpreted or thought as God as
something divine,
something spiritual,
something more advanced.
It was 100 percent Jesus because Jesus
was an alien.
No,
I just said that has nothing to do with
the New Testament,
Old Testament,
old testament.
God was an alien and Jesus,
no,
it was not god.
That's the thing that I thought it was
God.
Because see,
a lot of people say,
well,
does that mean you were an atheist?
Does that mean you don't believe in God?
And you know,
because a lot of the bunkers,
or actually creationists are always
using Albert Einstein as their best
example,
where they say,
see even Albert Einstein,
he believes in God,
so you know,
we must be right with our ideas.
Well,
that is only half of the story because
when Albert Einstein was asked as a
journalist,
a,
when a journalist asked Albert Einstein,
do you believe in God?
What Einstein said,
and anyone can go and look this up,
is the fact that he replied by saying,
well,
dear journalist,
before I can answer your question,
we have to define what your definition
or your idea of God is.
And then the journalists said,
well,
I believe in the Old Testament,
God and creator.
And then Albert said,
well,
if that is your definition of God,
than I respectfully will tell you that I
do not believe in God and Tony's like
wells in.
So what are you talking about?
An Einstein then explained his
definition are his idea of God and the
universe and the order that we have in
the universe.
And it's chaos.
And he said,
and if that is what what,
and this to me is my idea of God,
that there is some order to the universe
because you know,
God does not throw dice.
That's one of his most famous quotes.
So there in lies the difference that,
yes,
I do think that there is an all
encompassing force out there,
but it's not a personal god,
it's not where,
you know,
I pray and then all of a sudden,
I'm praying for something to happen.
I mean that to me is a waste of time to
be honest with you.
It's like if you want something to
happen,
you gotta go out there and do it
yourself no matter what.
But I think the reason why the idea of
prayer exists is because people can
manifest things with their own thoughts
and staying positive and focusing on a
goal and make yes to a certain extent
but thought.
But,
but that to me is just thought that the
idea of prayer,
prayer is just advanced thought,
right?
Just a moment to the moment that they
see that they're in,
to me,
that's where it gets wacky.
Because the moment that you correlate
your own power,
your own,
uh,
you know,
the connection to the universe that you
have,
the moment that you connect that to a
personal God and put everything that you
have,
you basically deny all responsibility
and you say,
okay,
fine,
God will take care of it.
That to me is such a cop out attitude.
It's like,
you know,
why know,
be responsible for your own actions and
don't rely on someone.
I completely agree.
But I think that that's where the idea
of prayer came from.
The reason why it exists to this day,
because you can sort of make things
happen if you focus on them for a long
period of time.
And people who have been successful at
making things happen have like stepped
back and said,
look,
you know,
we made this happen by prayer.
We've thought this through.
Can we get a crop top or open it up?
I'll just need one stop coughing for a
little second.
Poor little sicky Brian.
Now,
um,
you've been doing this for a long time
now.
You said 1998.
You started out your,
your,
your magazine.
How do you get approached to be doing
this ancient alien show?
How does this happen?
Did they just seek out people with,
you know,
sort of fringe beliefs and people that
are experts on these subjects?
No.
It was actually a very funny story and
that was,
if you remember,
in 2008 that New Indiana Jones movie
came out the Kingdom of the crystal
skull and it's kind of a disaster of a
movie.
I,
in my opinion,
but they're making another one.
Can you believe it?
To redeem themselves?
I hope they get worse.
It can't get.
It can't get worse.
They just don't seem to make in the
same.
Anyway,
the great thing about the movie itself
was the idea behind it was great,
but the execution was horrid.
It was basic.
An ancient alien movie where,
you know,
he was chasing the crystal skull.
The Crystal Skull happened to be an
extra terrestrial origin,
this and that.
So,
um,
the history channel made a two hour
documentary about Indiana Jones and the
feasibility behind,
uh,
you know,
all this stuff that he chased down.
And so it was one segment about crystal
skulls in which I appeared and talked
about the possibility whether to Chris
Mitchell hedges skull,
for example,
was in fact,
or could in fact be an extraterrestrial
artifact.
And the Mitchell hedges skull is what is
that the Mitchell had skull is one of
the most perfect,
the most perfect crystal m I t c h e l l
dash hedges h e d g e s Mitchell,
hedges skull.
And that skull was found in beliefs by,
by Michel headrest daughter on her
birthday.
And uh,
it's this crystal clear crystal that was
found in the shape of a humanoid head.
I mean,
it's massive.
It's really big.
If you go to the CRA,
Mitchell hedges.com,
they have a countdown to revelation.
It's gloom and doom once again.
I mean,
it's just crazy.
It's dope looking skull.
And what did you say about this called?
And some of them have been disproved,
right?
But this one hasn't.
And then there's no question about that.
And the fact that,
you know,
with this one here,
it's,
it's so magnificent where the,
you can actually detach the jawbone,
uh,
from it any which means that the pain,
it's from the same crystal,
which means it had to be one big fricken
rock out of which this whole thing was,
was made.
And when was it found?
Are they in the early 19 hundreds?
And when,
when Mitchell hedges or the actual,
um,
caretaker a after Mitchell had just died
and,
and Anna took over or kept the skull,
she and her,
this other dude who's name escapes me
right now,
I think it's Dan in this arena or
something.
They brought it in the 19 sixties to the
labs up in the bay area of Hewlett
Packard.
And even in the day,
of course,
only the best scientists worked at these
particular,
uh,
you know,
factories and labs.
And when the Hewlett Packard scientists,
we're done with all their research,
their conclusion was very simple.
And they said,
and I quote,
this,
golf should not exist.
And a meaning that it was,
they did not find any tool marks that
did not find any polished or any
evidence that this thing was polished or
anything like that.
And even more crazy is the fact that
each crystal,
it grows in a particular access.
And in order to work crystal,
you have to turn to crystal at high
speeds in that direction of the access.
And according to the Hewlett Packard
people,
it was ground against its grain and that
would shatter every crystal that you
would do this too.
And the crystal Hydros I mean the
Mitchell,
his skull,
um,
it,
it still exists and it shouldn't.
So it's,
it's a big mystery and yes,
like,
you know,
some crystal skulls have been determined
that they are,
you know,
modern day creations,
but not to Mitchell address.
Again,
that could be another tool that we're
not.
They used to have back in the day that
we're not thinking about that.
Right,
of course,
of course.
Sure.
Of course.
So this is how you got hooked up with
the history channel and then they're
like,
we like to do with crazy hair,
you know,
anything about Nazis.
No.
And denied.
Then I got a call and I was asking,
you know,
have I had,
I heard of a,
of a book called chariots of the Gods
and Eric Fund,
Danica.
And I said,
of course,
you know,
we publish a magazine together in this
and that and here we are today.
I mean,
it was just a,
an idea to,
to shoot a,
a two hour documentary 40 years after
chariots of the gods,
an argument
with a journalist when I first came to
Hollywood wasn't really an argument.
It was a talk at one of these.
They had these,
uh,
it was fox,
I was on Fox and had a party for a
Sitcom I was on.
And a guy said,
hey,
can I ask you a couple of questions?
And he goes,
okay.
So he rattles off a bunch of questions
and one of them was,
do you believe in aliens?
And uh,
I think I said yeah.
And he said,
why?
And I said,
well,
I saw this thing,
chariots of the gods,
and it's a pretty incredible movie and I
think it's,
it's more
than possible.
It's a lot of stars out there.
And he started going off on how chariots
of the gods it was bullshit.
And he goes,
oh,
it's been completely debunked.
And so I'm pretty calm about that kind
of stuff.
I go,
alright,
well how is it debunked?
And he had no answer.
And I said,
but yet you're so convinced that as
debunked.
But I know,
I know I read that had been debunked.
I go,
but you don't remember what you read,
but yet what did,
did you reach out to the gods?
And he's like,
no,
I didn't read it,
but I mean,
I know it's all about aliens.
And aliens came and made these
structures and was like,
wow,
dude,
you're pretty convinced.
But it was like a sensible man doesn't
believe such silly things.
And that is the,
the whole attitude about aliens,
about extra terrestrials or even about
ancient civilizations.
And these sensible man doesn't buy into
such nonsense.
And you must have had to deal with that
your whole fucking life.
Oh No,
absolutely.
And that's the thing where you just go
wacky with the hair and the jewelry and
I fucking bitch.
I'm going deep.
Yeah.
Crazy whole.
I'm still the same guy from 10 years
ago,
you know,
that's the thing that,
it's like,
to me,
you know,
especially the chariots of the gods
argument that,
you know from Danica has been debunked
and things like that.
It's like really,
I mean,
have you looked at this stuff?
Because the bottom line is that chariots
of the gods had over 200 question marks
in it and even had a fricking question
wanting to fucking title.
So,
I mean,
right,
there was a question.
It is a idea.
It's raising questions.
And if those questions happen to be
uncomfortable questions,
well,
you know what,
so be it because a couple of them are
wrong.
You're talking about a lot of Goddamn
questions.
No.
Here's the thing.
And let me,
let me ask you this.
When was the last time you saw as
scientist or,
or any author or whatever,
uh,
give,
you know,
30 years after they first publication
and say,
well,
you know,
on page,
so and so,
I made a mistake when chariots of the
gods came out as the 35 year addition to
35 year anniversary edition.
Eric wrote a 16 page of preface to the
new edition.
And in that he pointed out exactly what
we,
which mistakes he made in the 1968 or
1970 brooke on what page?
And on,
you know,
what happened here,
for example,
one example is the,
that uh,
uh,
the iron pillar in New Delhi for a long
time,
you know,
we thought that this might be something
that is of extraterrestrial origin or at
least that extra terrestrials taught
nice metallurgist.
How to poor this,
a pillar of iron because up to that time
it didn't corrode.
It didn't rust.
And it's been,
it had been around for many,
many years,
know hundreds and hundreds of years.
And guess what,
the thing is rusting today.
It's corroding.
So you know what that piece of evidence
out the,
you know what,
who cares?
Because the conclusion is that it in in
case a piece of evidence turns out to be
wrong or false.
If you eliminate that piece of evidence,
it only makes the overall theory
stronger because you eliminate false
stuff.
So to suggest that just because there
were a few mistakes and chairs of the
gods which Eric openly admitted to,
that doesn't mean that the whole ancient
alien theory all of a sudden becomes
irrelevant.
On the contrary,
it makes it more stronger.
And the fact that today,
especially on the show,
ancient aliens,
I mean,
by the way,
tomorrow is the premier of season three.
I'm very excited about that.
What's going on?
What's going well?
Can you preview us?
Can you tell us to have some scoops?
Any Nazi stuff?
There's definitely stuff in there that
has not been explored in the previous
season.
History channel needs to combine Nazis,
Ufo and ghost together and monsters.
One are fucking smash them up show.
And uh,
you know,
so I lost my train of thought was a
season of the history exactly his
special,
especially now in season three.
It's amazing how many university
professors have come forward and agreed
to be on a show called ancient fucking
aliens.
Are you kidding me?
The fact that university professors,
because as you know,
you,
you're in TV,
you have to disclose what show you're
calling from or what show you're going
to be on.
You can't just,
you know,
put a question mark there.
So the fact that university professors
are now coming forward,
especially for season three to appear on
that show,
I mean that speaks volumes.
I mean,
it's huge that,
that all of a sudden,
you know,
Eric von Daniken children's and I and
Martell and coppens,
we're surrounded by people from mit
talking about ancient aliens and what
exactly these,
uh,
professors about what is their,
their,
their subjects of expertise,
what do they,
uh,
well,
we,
we've,
for example,
in this episode that airs tomorrow and
Aliens and the old West,
we have a professor is not only do we
have elders,
a native American elders who are talking
about the idea of star people in,
in the ancient American west,
but also there are professors that we've
gotten from universities and curators of
museums where they corroborate the
stories about the star people.
And so which one do they do that well
because they,
they are,
uh,
they have access to many,
many recordings that were written down
by a previous,
um,
in the old west.
Things for the first time would be able
to be recorded because in ancient native
American times their traditions were
brought from generation to generation
and words.
Spoken words.
Exactly.
And then when white men came,
I guess unfortunately the,
you know,
the whole thing was recorded all of a
sudden.
And so we have very old recordings
talking about these star people that
came allegedly a long time ago.
And so that is a huge,
huge part of our theory that there are
entire cultures,
for example,
native Americans that talk about the
Kachinas descending from the sky in
flying shields.
And they were very adamant because of
course native Americans,
you know,
believe in the spiritual realm,
there's no question,
but they're also very adamant to say
that there are two worlds,
there is the spiritual realm.
And then there is also the physical
realm and vet the star.
People were part of the physical realm.
And here we are to say,
oh well,
you know,
they didn't know what they were talking
because they were just all,
hi there,
we're getting that pod.
Which,
you know,
I mean,
of course there is not one culture in
the world that did not dabble in,
in mind altering drugs.
I mean,
it's just a,
a,
a complete,
uh,
it's who we are as a people.
There is no question about that,
but at the same time there were always
these different levels that yes,
there's absolutely no doubt in my mind
that the spiritual realm does exist,
but we also have a physical realm in
which our ancestors said that somebody
came in a physical form,
so you think that there's probably some
sort of an advanced life or some sort of
a different life in a,
in a nonmaterial form as well.
Like there's some sort of a spiritual
realm,
100 percent chin or something like have
something,
something else,
some sort of intelligent life,
and then there's physical life is,
and you know me,
I'm the nuts and bolts alien guy.
Right?
But at the same time I would be a fool
to deny or to even suggest that that a
ethereal realm does not exist because
that would render our physical world
completely useless if that's all there
is.
Because a lot of people are saying,
well,
you know,
if you die,
all it's going to happen is that,
you know,
they're gonna basically just pull the
plug from the computer.
Hard drive and things like that.
And that's usually the argument that
they give,
but the bottom line is that's not
necessarily true because if you keep
your computer in a very safe place and
you can leave it there unplugged for a
years.
If you find a power source a million
years down the road and you plug that
computer back in,
guess what?
Everything on that hard drive is still
there.
So what if the hard drive is to soul?
And therefore once we die,
our souls goes with us.
That's who we are as an essence.
Yes we will leave this body,
but at the same time energy does not
die.
It goes on in some form.
So to suggest that after this life,
it's all over.
I cannot process that.
Do Kurtzweil and Ray Kurzweil's ideas of
downloading human consciousness into,
into intelligent computers.
And the idea of your,
you will be able to duplicate yourself
and live forever in some sort of cyber
environment.
I think it's fascinating and you know
what happens with the,
you know,
the spiritual version of you.
If that takes place,
you know,
well maybe then that's where you live
inside that,
inside that saddle zombies.
Yeah,
no,
but the thing is you see,
and that's why you know,
movies like the Matrix are so the first
one was so wonderful because those are
all fantastic,
interesting ideas.
But to me I'm a big subscriber to
reincarnation and uh,
what I think because that because of
energy not being able to die,
and I think our soul,
our essence,
his energy,
it's part of this all encompassing force
that to me is the universe or God.
And so you know,
if you have,
if you look for example,
at the dialogue or a lot of Buddhists
who believe in reincarnation or Hindus
and things like that,
they always talk about how you will get
reincarnated here on planet earth as
another being or another animal or
whatever.
But see,
to me that's all very limited thinking
because while I do subscribe to
reincarnation,
there is no way,
in my opinion that we would only
reincarnate here on earth.
We can reincarnate throughout the entire
universe.
And that is why some people,
when they come back to Earth,
they're considered maybe old souls or
they're more intuitive to everything
that they might've been here before.
So using this one universal bank of
souls for the entire universe and that
everybody has to tip into it no matter
what you know,
on planet fucking serious or whatever,
you know,
you,
you all did for the same souls.
And so like,
you could die here and then reemerge on
planet,
go fuck yourself in the middle of
nowhere and somehow somehow with a,
but somehow with the same quote unquote
instinct or knowledge because there's
something that's out there.
It's called the,
the eternal spirit.
And that is,
uh,
that we all consist of,
of particles and elements.
And every 60 days our entire bodies are,
are completely recycled because I mean,
we're,
we're completely changing tickets every
seven years.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
whatever I did or it's the,
it's the complete resection of a body,
which is absolutely mind boggling.
Yeah,
it's pretty crazy.
It's seven years and we're being
bombarded by this cosmic dust.
And that is what we consist of.
And this is one of French philosopher
John Shiran in his book called the
eternal spirit.
Uh,
the internal internal particles
suggested that,
um,
each time one of our particles in our
body travels through the universe,
no matter what it passes through,
if it's a stone or a or some type of a
being or something,
it records everything.
And so,
you know,
each and every particle contains the
knowledge of the entire universe.
And that's within us.
I mean,
it's the theory of things.
Recording things by Rupert Sheldrake,
Tony,
you know who he is.
Yes,
he has a,
some sort of theory that things
contained memory,
houses,
tables,
chairs,
everything.
Because we're all made of the same
stuff.
And if that,
you know,
if these particles all record the same
stuff,
then you know,
we are all one.
See if you take a piece of skin and you
put it underneath the electron
microscope and you go deeper and deeper
and deeper and deeper,
everything wobbles.
Everything vibrates.
It's all exciting down there.
And uh,
you know,
that's just who we are.
We consist of a vibration frequency.
It's all harmonics.
Now you take a piece of this Metal Cup
right here,
which is considered to be inorganic or
dead material and you put a little
little piece under the same electron
microscope and you go deeper and deeper
and deeper.
At the very,
very core,
it's the exact same thing and I would
challenge you for 100 bucks to tell me
which is which.
Nobody can tell.
I can tell the difference unless you
know exactly which means we all exist of
the same stuff.
Don't we all exist?
It actually has nothing.
I mean isn't like most of the universe
and nothing changed.
The universe's most.
Mostly Adams and most adams are almost
entirely nothing and end.
We consist of nothing too because while
we can touch ourselves and touch other
people and the sensation of touch and
all this,
it's all complete its magnetism.
I mean,
should use that as a trial,
you know,
grab some chicks ass.
I've touched nothing was nothing to
touch.
I have a question.
A lot of the stuff you're saying I agree
with and a lot of stuff they're saying.
Edgar Casey for instance,
he was a.
he,
he believed in the Akashic records and
then he,
um,
he can put them,
he put his,
he put himself under hypnosis,
right?
Yes.
Self hypnosis.
And then when he was an under south
hypnosis,
he became this brilliant all knowing
man.
And he had a third grade education and
he's,
he said that he's all,
this information can be tapped into by
anybody.
Just got to learn like meditation is
part of it and that's why there's a big,
you know,
meditation is huge and Yoga is huge
because once you master meditation,
you actually can tap into the Akashic
records which holds the answers to
everything.
Where you Edgar Casey Fan,
did you follow him at all?
No,
actually I really don't know much about
him.
But uh,
you know,
it is true that you see we only use
about five percent of our entire brain
power.
Is that really true?
I've heard that's been debunked.
Well,
even if let's say,
let's say it's,
let's say it's 10 percent,
don't even think that's true.
I think they've debunked it.
I think that was back when people were
ignorant as about the functions of
different areas of the brain and now
they've attributed different areas of
the brain,
two different functions and I think the
more they understand about the brain,
the more they realize that that's,
that's a misnomer.
Have you driven down to four or five?
You know,
he's still,
believe it or not,
I'm not.
I'm not saying that these people are
thinking,
well,
they even said like if you use more than
10 percent at the same time,
it would just go into seizures and
stuff.
I think that's all worship.
I think that's all been disproven.
I'm almost positive.
Yeah,
I believe what you were saying.
Well anyway,
so,
so the idea,
let's,
let's operate under the assumption that
you know,
we,
we only use about eight,
five to eight percent of our total brain
power is one guy suggested a
philosopher.
He said that the brain is the last
untamed beast in the universe.
And that is true because every single
thing that we see each day,
every single thing that we hear,
everything that we say,
our brains records it all.
Everything is there,
everything is there permanently for
eternity in our brains.
The only problem is we can't access the
information.
And then of course there are people who
are great at,
you know,
memorizing lines or memorizing texts or,
or whatever or you know,
we'll have photographic memory,
autism where they could,
I mean,
well,
you know,
and,
and also,
you know,
normally quote unquote functioning
people.
I mean,
you know,
it's,
uh,
it's amazing how,
you know,
some people have the code and code gift
to recall certain things and some people
don't.
And that is where I think,
you know,
the last frontier lies that,
uh,
we could conceivably access way more of
our brain power and then you could move
proverbial mountains.
The 10 percent of the brain is
absolutely a myth.
Yeah.
It's,
yeah,
it's absolutely been proven.
It is actually a misinterpretation,
a misquote of Albert Einstein or the
misinterpretation of the work of Pierre
Florins in the 18 hundreds.
It's a,
we use 100 percent of our brain.
They haven't mapped out.
They know what part of your brain works
for different areas that did not know at
a certain point in time in history.
And that's when people started,
you know,
kind of chirping that and sending it
back and forth.
So through the wonders of the Internet,
we just cleared that up.
And this is why you never stop learning.
Never.
Every day you learn something new.
Um,
what do you think about all this Nazi
shit because,
uh,
one of the things that's fascinating
about the ancient aliens show is how
much the Nazis were into the occult and
uh,
the,
the Mahabharata and trying to recreate
things that were in ancient scriptures
mean being Indiana Jones thing.
They kind of got into it with the,
um,
the um,
the,
what is it called,
the Ark of the covenant and you know,
and that there's.
So there's something to it.
And the Nazis were obsessed with that
shit,
but if they were just some fucking
Kooks,
you know,
which they clearly were in one way,
but there were also sell fucking vance
with rocketry.
And with science and you know,
I mean somebody companies came out of
Nazi Germany,
you know,
there's just Germany period for getting
the Nazi matter.
So,
I mean,
the Porsche started there,
you know,
bmw,
some,
somebody,
sophisticated engineers there were so
advanced.
What the fuck was there?
A big thing about Ufo is where was the
whole Nazi ufo connection because that
was one of the most fascinating ancient
aliens to me.
Yeah,
no,
look,
I mean there's definitely something that
can be said about this.
And uh,
the whole idea because many scholars say
that,
you know,
Hitler and the Nazis were never into the
occult and that is simply untrue because
we have found or they found a documents
because they're,
the Nazis were immaculate.
The record keepers as we know,
and uh,
it says that these expeditions to the
North Pole to find openings at the North
Pole and the South Pole,
that these expeditions truly did exist,
that the real society and the Tulip
society really existed in things like
that.
And I personally find fascinating.
But I gotta be honest with you.
You know that to me it's not ancient
enough.
Talk about Egos because that was 70
years ago.
My,
my ancient aliens,
uh,
you know,
some people consider a 70 year old
people,
ancient,
but you know,
I don't.
So uh,
my aliens happened thousands of years,
so you a Sumerian Mesopotamia and Egypt,
ancient Greece and things like that,
but at the same time,
you know,
you just never know.
And it would be foolish to not listen to
those stories or to look at these
opinions because you just never know.
Just be open at all times.
Isn't there like a bunch of faces and
paintings that have like old a drawing
is an alien's on them and stuff like
that.
And have those been disproven or have
those,
uh,
are,
are the.
Because I've seen a few of them where
they're like,
yeah,
this is an alien.
I'm like,
yeah,
that or it's just a guy that has his
head shaved and the artists sucks,
you know,
if you've done in any research on that
kind of stuff or.
No,
I mean one of the greatest,
uh,
quote unquote pieces of evidence we have
is,
you know,
the,
the deaf,
um,
the carvings that we find,
but also the figurines and drawings on
vases,
like what you were saying and there
really are compelling figurines and
compelling drawings that compared to
modern days are eerily similar to modern
day astronauts suits and you know,
a lot of times that the bunkers are
like,
okay,
so you're suggesting that the aliens
we're here and why on earth would they
wear to same suits or why would they
need suits like our modern day
astronauts because they were only a
little more advanced us.
Right?
Exactly.
But there were us in 100 years but we
would need suits.
Right?
But that.
But that's the exact argument that if we
can't go to the moon without a suit,
so why would aliens if they're,
you know,
have oxygen based to people as we are
or,
or people that need to breathe oxygen
for,
for their life support.
So to suggest that aliens are so vastly
different than us that I have a hard
time with that.
I mean,
there's some people that have suggested
that aliens are just these,
you know,
uh,
blobs of slime and I'm like,
okay,
that's possible.
But,
you know,
that would define nature because nature
is very efficient and I think that the
building blocks that are requirements
for life are pretty much a given
throughout the entire universe.
And so that if something happens here,
you know,
to,
to think that aliens would exist,
like in the Hollywood movies,
that's a bit too much for me.
I mean,
look,
it's great entertainment,
but do I think that that is how it is in
reality?
Not really.
I think that we're all pretty much,
you know,
the same out there,
um,
you know,
more advanced obviously,
but it looks nice because all those
ancient uh,
carvings or descriptions and paintings
that we have,
you know,
especially if you look at the ancient
Hindu gods,
they look like us.
Beautiful.
But just with blue skin for example,
but they weren't,
they didn't have four in India.
Yes,
they did have 20 arms,
but you know,
so it's definitely something to be said
that,
you know,
we think that we have depictions that
show potential exit through restroom
visits,
visitors in the past.
You must dominate some late night hippie
pussy sitting around with,
you know what I'm saying,
sitting around smoking weed with some
chicks at a party and you drop some of
this ancient alien knowledge dude,
you must just knock it out of the
fucking park.
Or should I say have in the past or
should I say have the potential to.
I don't say you use it for evil.
Never evil,
never evil.
Do you believe in or what do you think
about the reptilian shape?
Shifting genre,
complete nonsense.
The David acres.
So many nonsense.
He's got so many good points but a
little things.
But you mentioned Shane shapeshifting
earlier this the possibility to turn
into clouds are trees.
Yeah,
but I.
But I would not say that that's only
reserved for reptilians.
I mean,
look,
I really think that.
I don't know.
I mean the whole argument with the whole
reptilian thing.
Look,
it really doesn't matter because what
this theory or this whole extra
terrestrial question is about is whether
or not extraterrestrial life not only
has been here,
but also whether they're here right now
and you know what,
whether their reptilian or if they look
like link the Loompa's he doesn't
matter.
The fact is that having an
extraterrestrial presence on planet
earth,
not only today,
but for thousands of years,
that is sensational enough then to
suggest,
yeah,
you know,
they're coming from planet so and so
their space ships name is so and so.
Their commander's name was so and so.
I mean,
that is,
to me,
all irrelevant garbage and that is why
the mainstream is not listening to these
stories because they're completely,
it's complete buffoonery to suggest,
you know,
what plant they're from,
what their spaceships name was with the
propulsion system was.
I mean,
it's all nonsense.
Who gives a shit extra terrestrials
we're an art here.
That's all that should matter to you.
That I'm sorry.
No,
no,
no.
Do you um,
believe Robert Loser?
Do you believe his stories?
You know,
I was just thinking about him.
Him and John Lear,
John Lear's,
out of the craziest theories ever,
John Lear believes that there are
millions of humanoids on every planet in
the solar system and we've been to all
the planets.
There's a CPA,
he's Kooky,
crazy shit.
But,
but Robert Lasar is not so cookie.
Robert Lazard is a,
I think he's probably full of shit about
some things for sure.
But he's also a very intelligent guy and
god damn,
he sounds confident as fuck when he
gives you his depictions to pictures of
what happened at area 51 and where he
worked.
And you know,
it's interesting,
you know,
uh,
I don't,
I don't know if he's telling the truth,
but from what I understand,
he lied about his education.
He lied about where he went to school
and they've,
you know,
they've proven that he didn't get
degrees where he said he got degrees.
So I dunno,
you know,
but again,
could be more disinflation,
could be more.
He was really good friends with John
later.
They were buddies.
And that's not good because that John
Lear guys out to lunch,
or John Lear says that the moon is a
spaceship right now.
He says that that's where your soul goes
to.
It's a song catcher.
When you die,
your soul goes to the moon.
See,
that to me is nonsense.
It's just right there and say,
okay,
look,
never say never.
But that right there,
you're going to lose the mainstream
audience.
And listen,
that Guy John,
I'd say,
if anybody's a dis information guys,
John Lear,
lear jets,
guys worth fucking $50 million dollars
is out there running around talking
about the moon,
catching souls.
When you die,
you live in Ron.
Jeremy,
tell us about some episodes that some
subject or subjects that you guys are
going to cover that you didn't cover.
The first two things because he did the
cowboy thing.
That's pretty good.
Yeah,
no,
but for example,
we're talking about the entire churches
and buildings that were,
that are carved into the ground in
Ethiopia at zoom and Baylor were
apparently a a version or possibly the
Ark of the covenant is still buried in a
town called act soon.
Now that's what got Graham Hancock into
his whole journey that he went on.
He wouldn't say mainstream reporter,
and he was covering some political
unrest in Ethiopia and he started
talking to some of the people that guard
the temple that where they say the Ark
of the covenant is inside.
And uh,
he,
uh,
was very compelled by the evidence and
the history behind it.
And what do you think about it?
Well,
for example,
I mean every week they have a procession
through the town where they carry a
replica of the Ark around and uh,
it's obviously a replica.
Unfortunately,
you,
nobody has access to the arc except for
this family,
for who,
for generations have been guarding this
arc.
And what's really fascinating is that
each and every guardian of that arc,
they eventually go blind,
which is really fascinating to think
that,
you know,
you're guarding this object that only
you are allowed to see if at all.
And each and every one of these guards
has gone blind.
Many,
how many you,
oh,
we're talking at least 350 years.
Record it of people go on blind faith
that I go,
bitch,
you could have that job.
Well,
they may not have lava and you get this
arc of the covenant.
Why is it so awesome that it's willing
to make you go blind?
And that is the exact question.
I mean,
so something is going on there unless
it's a hoax.
And,
and the stories have been made up to
think that man who,
uh,
told Graham Hancock about it had
cataracts,
you know,
that was the,
one of the things that led him to start
investigating.
But I have heard that too many of the
people that have been in the care of
this thing had been blocked.
So what do they think?
They think that it's radioactive and
some sort of a way possibly,
possibly.
I mean,
according to what is it supposed to be?
Well,
according to the ancient astronauts
theory that I represent,
the Ark of the was nothing else but a
container in which an extra terrestrial
food dispensing device was stored in
food dispensing.
Yes,
like an extra terrestrial vending
machine.
Exactly.
I like that.
I'm going to,
I'm going to steal that from you.
I liked that very much.
So the Ark of the covenant is nothing
but a fucking vending machine,
but it's a great time.
So that basically,
how did you come to that conclusion?
Look in the 19 seventies,
these two engineers then of Rodney Dale
and George says they wrote a book called
the man and machine and if you look at
Mana,
meaning the,
the,
the breadth of that fell from heaven.
Exactly.
And uh,
they ancient astronaut people and the
mushroom people need to get together,
come up with a unified theory of crazy
because that's what they believe.
Monetize.
I'm sorry.
No,
don't worry.
So there is a,
uh,
in the Hebrew Zahar than there is a.
sorry.
In,
in the,
um,
in the Kabbalah,
there a text in the Kabbalah called
Zahar.
And the so hard describes a,
an ancient of days that the traveled
with a 40 year wanderings through the
desert at this ancient of days was with
them all the time.
At the ancient of days has been
interpreted,
interpret as the Old Testament God.
And so these two engineers came along
and theoretic description of it and they
said,
you know what,
this does not sound like a dad at all,
but it sounds like some type of a
machine.
Now mind you,
those guys were engineers,
electrical engineers,
so they weren't some hobbyists or
something like this.
And one guy was also a linguist at the
same time.
So they looked at all these translations
and look at all the,
uh,
the different interpretations.
And they found that some of the earliest
translations of the ancient of days
wasn't in fact the ancient of days.
But the transportable,
one of the tanks now that is very
bizarre that you have this thing that
had to be disassembled and assembled
every week on different,
uh,
on,
after a certain amount of time where
this machine or this object was taken
apart with different parts that were
connected with cubes.
And there was a huge light source.
And it was just this magnificent thing
that they determined,
dispensed the Mana through big giant
tanks.
And also through tubes.
And things like this,
um,
that,
uh,
you know,
that is the reason why we have to the
Sabbath today because on the sabbath the
machine had to be cleaned.
So all those differently.
This is wild stuff,
wild and crazy stuff,
but at the same time it's very
compelling because the texts are exactly
saying that that on Friday and Saturday
you're not going to get fed because this
quarter and called dad had to be taken
apart and cleaned and it wasn't
extremely meticulous and dangerous
process.
People died.
People who did not know how to operate
or how to conduct themselves in the
presence of this transportable off the
tanks.
They dropped to the floor dead and then
they would lose their fingernails.
They would have a minute ago,
you broke my crazy meter.
Broken.
My Shit's broken night.
It don't work anymore.
Good.
I don't know what you're saying anymore.
I don't even know what you're saying.
My job.
I have done my job.
Try to throw your shit in my brain what
you were saying about this machine and
then my,
my,
my brain's going,
what the fuck are you asking me?
Do you think it's possible that there
was like this ancient machine that
killed everybody?
Why would they do that?
Was there a shortage of fully back then?
Could they just go get food?
Maybe the food.
They had awesome food.
It took an ice cream truck back in the
time machine.
People would freak the shit with an ice
cream cone.
The pushy that you would get initially,
there are ancient stories where they
talk about magical glowing tablets that
contained the universe.
The universal knowledge was to take.
If you take that,
those were iphones back to the,
you know,
10,000
years ago,
you have a magical tablet all of a
sudden.
Yeah.
It is true.
Well,
you know,
like I said,
I believe that there's some shit that
human beings have discovered a long
fucking time ago and then rediscovered
it if human beings created the pyramids
and that is the general consensus.
Right,
and I agree with that.
Definitely human beings,
but with the assistance of exit
terrestrial technology,
because that is what ancient texts,
for example,
the all had taught,
Kita are saying,
written by the Egyptian historian on the
Chrissy,
that the pyramids were built by
[inaudible],
which was a king and his people with the
assistance of the guardians of the sky.
And in our interpretation,
of course,
the guardians of the sky.
We're advanced flesh and blood could
terrestrials who taught mankind how to
use certain machinery Yo [inaudible]
Zachariah such and believed that the
pyramids were never tunes that were
never built as soon as he,
he believes that they were beacons for
the is.
Yes.
I mean,
that is definitely a possibility
personally.
Uh,
I,
I agree with the notion that the
pyramids were never tombs because,
uh,
even when the first time that the
pyramids were allegedly the seals were
broken,
uh,
no,
no actual bodies were found in there.
And what's really fascinating is the
fact that,
you know,
the pyramids defied every single other
co structure in Egypt because you walk
inside any tomb in Egypt and there the
walls are filled with hieroglyphics.
And,
and really,
I mean it says exactly when it was built
by whom and how and when and what and
where,
and you go inside the pyramids and
they're completely anonymous except for
a couple of cartoons.
That debate is still out whether or not
these cartoon shows are in fact before
juries were not,
so that that mystery has not yet been
solved.
And despite what mainstream
archaeologists saying when they've dated
the Great Pyramid,
back to 2,500
BC,
what have they used to data?
What is the.
Oh,
they,
they basically,
um,
see that?
I know.
I love that you just asked that question
because the great misunderstanding is
that when there's a lot of people that
say,
you know,
when they dated the Sphinx or when they
dated the pyramid and when they,
and right there you can,
you need to take a step back because
nobody was actually able to do that
because you can't really date stone
because the stone is an inorganic
material.
If you carbon date something with this,
what they call the c 14 or carbon 14
method.
With dating,
you can only date something that's of a
living material like bones or coal or
textiles and things like that because
what they do is they measure the half
life period of radioactive isotopes and
so that's how you can accurately date,
for example,
a,
um,
you know,
an old fire pit that has been found and
many times archeologists are dating a
firepit and then they come up with a
particular lady yields that the test
yields a particular date,
let's say,
uh,
you know,
500 BC and then they say,
well,
okay,
that means that the site itself also
dates from 500 BC.
And that,
in my opinion is a logical fallacy
because just because a firepit bates to
500 BC doesn't mean that was also built
in 500 BC.
They can't date stones.
Right,
exactly.
So how do they do good Beckley Tepi,
how do they say that?
That thing is 12,000
years old with,
with,
with the fire pits and the bones that
were found in and around that area.
So it's still absolutely so,
which means that the stones themselves
could date back even further.
It would be way newer APP.
Yes,
of course.
Look Weird.
Are they using go Beckley Teppei though
for folks I don't know.
It's right now considered to be the
oldest structure ever discovered and
they're saying that it's 6,000
years before Mesopotamian Sumir,
which was previously considered to be
the cradle of civilization,
the oldest.
And they're saying that this was all
constructed,
but I can people were hunter gatherers,
but if that is what they're saying,
I mean how can you say that if it's just
like fire pit shit and bones and
whatever.
Right.
The thing is also that,
you know on,
on the little Mediterranean island in
Malta,
which is right next to Sicily,
there are megalithic structures.
Megalithic meaning gigantic stones that
are,
you know,
250 500 metric tons heavy slabs that
have been transported from somewhere
else put into place with incredible
precision.
And some of these have data to 12,000
BC when allegedly we were just,
you know,
munching on bananas and how do they date
these to 12,000
BC?
What are they also again with,
with bones and with having found fire
pits.
But that does not mean that the stones
themselves have been placed there even
earlier.
There is a,
uh,
a method out there called,
called the thermo luminescent,
a dating method of stone where,
uh,
you can conceivably date stone bites.
It's a bit inaccurate because what
happens is if you Polish or cut a stone,
the oxygen in the air,
there's a chemical reaction that takes
place with the surface of that stone and
they can somehow somehow measure this
has been cut.
Exactly.
And,
but it's a very expensive way of testing
something.
So in many universities unfortunately
don't have the money.
So they don't do that.
The third way is we're each time that
you have an ancient stone overtime,
because we were talking before about
erosion and if you have thousands of
years of rainfall,
what is left over?
You gave the answer,
you said rocks.
And that is exactly right.
So over time,
what forms over a rock is this thin film
that just built,
it's called a Patina.
And the thicker this film or this Patina
is the older the stone.
So people have in fact been able to
measure the Patina and people have
determined that some of these cuts are
thousands and thousands of years old,
meaning they're not modern day creations
and right there it just boggles the mind
because it was certainly not cut with
blondes.
Tools are with chicken bones.
As we were led to believe.
If you had the opportunity right now,
if the government came and they picked
you up and air force one and flew to
Washington and said,
listen to,
we're gonna,
we're gonna offer you something I didn't
know you know a lot about the shit we
could use you.
We're going to show you some shit and
when you needed to help us.
But you can't tell anybody.
You've got to quit your all your ancient
alien stuff.
You've got to quit your magazine.
You got to work for the government and
tell no one.
And they monitor your fucking calls.
If you telling anybody you're dead,
but they're going to take an area 51 and
they're going to take you to Wright
Patterson air force base to hang 18 and
they're going to show you all that shit.
Would you be down?
They're going to show you the ancient
show
you everything.
You know the answer.
Yes.
You would do it right?
Yeah.
You'd give up on civilization and be a
suit.
Of course.
I might be to.
I might do it two.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm,
I quit comedy.
Quit comedy to learn about the aliens
because it helped me,
you know,
if you knew,
if you knew for a fact,
would it help?
Would we just sit around waiting for the
ambulance to come?
And then when they didn't want you be
disappointed.
I mean,
if you do know that there are aliens out
there and they're monitoring you,
like,
come on,
make something happen.
Oh,
here,
here's something I would like to put on
the record.
Hear that personally,
I have never seen a Ufo.
I have never been visited.
I have never had any,
uh,
you know,
an abduction experience or anything like
this.
So because a lot of people asked me that
and then I tell them,
no,
actually I haven't been there like,
well then how do you subscribe to these
ideas?
And I'm like,
well,
because you know,
to me this has really nothing to do with
belief because belief always has this
quote unquote religious connotation.
It means that if you believe something,
you have to have faith.
I don't have faith in aliens,
I don't worship them.
I don't quote unquote think of them as
spiritual or divine beings.
There are people like us just more
advanced technologically speaking.
So to me it's more of an idea of,
of knowing instead of believing I think
about these things.
It's not,
you know,
that I quote unquote bullying.
So you think there's a broad spectrum of
aliens out there?
Like there's some of them that are just
like a little more advanced than us.
Like they could visit us and maybe maybe
fuck us and gold.
Sure.
And there's other ones that are like
super advanced that are just showing up
as clouds and monitoring us and
explosions.
Is
this a thing out there where this guy,
Carter chef is Soviet scientist in the
sixties and seventies actually came up
with this,
the classification of civilizations,
and he said that there's basically three
types of civilizations out there,
type one,
type two,
type three,
type one civilization is.
And it's all about energy because in the
end that's all what it comes down to.
And uh,
he basically suggested that a type one
civilization is capable of harnessing
the energy resources of their own home
planet.
A type two civilization is able to
harness the energy resources of their
solar system.
And a type three civilization is able to
harness the energy resources of their
own galaxy.
Now we on this scale are were none.
We are type zero civilization on the
verge of becoming a type one
civilization.
So Sagan,
Carl Sagan actually suggested that we're
maybe a point seven or possibly now a
point eight and many of these
astronomers and astrophysicists are
suggesting that this transitionary
period from a type zero type one is the
most difficult and most dangerous one
because it does involve the splitting of
the atom or monkeys altogether.
And monkeys,
you know,
so I mean this is all,
it's all fascinating stuff.
Brian Asleep one thing I was going to
ask you about before when you studied,
they found those little things,
they rebuild and upper propellers on
them and they were like a plane.
I saw the pictures of those,
but it also looks like they kind of
modified the,
uh,
the,
the wings a little bit to make it
actually fly a,
what could it have been just easily like
a statue of a bird or,
or,
or something like that.
Why is it all just they put routers,
it doesn't look like they modified the
wings on a,
on the actual statute is just like a
flat,
you know,
that has to be curved in order for it to
get flight,
you know?
Yeah.
But the thing is that it actually,
um,
in,
in the same collection of,
of um,
the totems or robbed or found.
They did find carvings or creations of
birds and they look totally different.
Yes.
And fish and crocodiles and what he was
talking about earlier too about the
wings being on the bottom and the
fuselage.
And all that shit is like the rudder on
the top.
There's no animal in the history of the
cars.
That fucking thing.
Right.
Um,
let me see some of those pictures you
brought him in because he brought in
some bad ass structures.
And this is a your own collection.
Yeah.
This is stuff that I,
that I took a all around the world now,
for example,
you know,
because I was saying earlier that
obviously our ancestors did know how to
cut stone and move objects and move
stone blocks and things like that.
So there's absolutely no question about
that.
They did know how to do this,
but I'm going to show you a physical
impossibility right now where I still
today,
I show these pictures at each and every
one of my lectures and I have yet anyone
to come forward and tell me how this was
done.
And I've taught,
I've shown these pictures to engineers
to stone cutters and things like that.
And if they're like,
this can't be done.
So if you look,
for example,
at this structure right here,
obviously it's a type of a stone quarry.
We're blocks were cut out so you know,
there's no question that stone blocks
where were actually cut out of these
particular sections.
Right?
Right there.
However,
if you,
and this year is on the back entrance in
Peru in an area called a orientate
tombow and uh,
what you have here is a two blocks that
were cut out of the side of the
mountain,
one at the very top where if you look
closely at the,
uh,
at this particular photograph,
the top one,
the top block or the top slab was
released by,
you know,
having three cards on the left and the
right in the bottom.
And then one blade that went down on the
back.
But now I want you to pay attention to
the bottom square of this particular,
um,
slap it was cut out where you can see
the four sites have been cut out and
then the back.
But there is no access point to this
particular,
uh,
to the back.
Because if you look closely the bridge
that connects or that is between the top
part or the top slab that was cut out.
And the bottom one,
there is no access point,
it's a solid piece.
And so I see what you're saying.
Right?
So what you're saying is that the top
one you could slide behind it and cut it
out because you could get at the top of
it.
This one,
there's like a bridge and as no way to
get behind it and write it up.
And as if somebody wants to have a good
time,
the actual block that fit into the
bottom slot is sitting right next to it,
as we say.
Maybe they just destroyed it.
No,
no,
no.
You could see it and hear it is cut out.
Check it out.
So,
and that piece right there,
that blog has not a single millimeter of
loss of material.
So it's not like a carved around it or
something.
I mean this is a physical impossibility.
And the only way that somebody,
uh,
you know,
give an idea how this could have been
been possible is you have a piece of
this is I really wish we had photos of
this that we could show people.
I mean,
this is,
um,
W can they look up,
we're going to look up on the
[inaudible].
This is really fascinating.
What is the name of this stone and what
could they look up online if they want
to do with this yet broke?
How many people are looking at this at a
fraction?
I can send you,
I can send you the,
what should,
what should they look for this?
This,
this is we untaped tombow o l l a n t a
y t a,
b Oriente.
Tom Is in Peru in Peru.
And it's a in the backs in the quarry of
that archaeological site.
It's fucking incredible.
Now I got a question.
What would the fuck is up with Peru?
Man,
there's so much crazy shit in Peru with
the Nasco lines,
Machu Picchu,
those crazy people,
the skulls with a,
uh,
the deformed their skulls and make
themselves look like fucking the
coneheads,
the Eland,
gator craniums is a cone.
Heads is definitely at a,
below the same error.
Is it all combined?
Yes and no.
I mean,
look,
one thing that's really great in my
opinion is that the archeologists agree
that in Peru has the culture to the
culture,
the ancient culture of Peru,
the Incas,
and what's fascinating is the fact that
today,
the archeologists agree that a pre inca
civilization did in fact exist,
but not a single archeologist agrees who
the hell those pre inca people were.
So this is where you know,
your previous idea in theory definitely
comes into place or fits,
that there was a type of highly advanced
civilization back in the past that
nobody knows even know what date and
some have suggested 10,
15,000
years ago that that civilization might
have been wiped out because Puma Plinko
for example,
is such an era of such a region or a
site that was 100 percent built by pre
buy,
buy a pri inconsideration and still
today archeologists are fighting over
who these people were.
We had a buddy on the other day,
Thompson had been demonstrably feature
several times and I was saying that I
had read something,
I believe it was Graham Hancock
speculation about launch Picchu.
That at one point in time it was at the
side of water isn't not true.
Puma,
Puma.
What?
It wasn't,
wasn't much a pitcher.
In fact Puma.
Puma is translated.
It's but it's miles away from water
right now,
right?
Yes,
yes.
But it's right next to.
It's right next to Lake Titicaca,
which is the highest navigable lake in
the world at 12 and a half thousand feet
and still today,
the,
the train,
the train tracks that drive or to go
through with the Bolivian highlands and
the proven highlands are filled with
muscles and with fish bones that are
thousands and thousands of years old
proving that that area used to be under
seawater.
We're not talking,
we're not.
Yeah,
we're not talking,
you know,
fresh water.
We're talking seawater.
So I mean,
so people were punk who was built as an
ocean port.
Yes.
And that is even something that
mainstream archaeologists have proposed
as well.
And how old is supposed to be then?
Well that would mean it goes back to the
last ice age.
Socially we're at 14,000
years ago.
So all these Dasko lines and the top of
the Nazca lines isn't there like clear
evidence that area has been excavated by
machine.
I mean there are entire mountain tops at
Mrs are missing to have been as if with
a cheese knife.
But I know that it was higher.
I mean what is the proof?
Well,
because you have a mountain ranges right
next door,
not even 100 yards away or 200 yards
away or a certain height of a certain
height and you know,
and,
and the other ones are completely like,
they're like table top level is level
100 percent real affection.
Do you play pool on it?
Absolutely.
Really should go play some NASCAR,
Nascar Pool right now.
What is the mainstream opinion of what
those lines are?
Ford's very clear.
You could only see them from the sky if
they are just artwork their artwork for
fucking who fucking exactly how big are
they?
They are,
there is.
Nazca is fascinating because you have a
world famous geoglyphs and mainly you
people see the,
the,
uh,
the images of the spider and the monkey
astronaut astronaut,
by the way,
the astronaut who looks like eat with
the big eyes,
one hand is pointing to the sky,
the other hand is pointing to is both
suck my dick.
That's sort of space with his dick.
Um,
and so,
uh,
you know,
but at the same time you have those
lines that look like landing trips that
look like landing strips.
And by the way,
we never suggest that that they actually
were landing strips because the argument
is completely ridiculous because what
extraterrestrials traveled millions and
billions of light years plan before they
can land is to get a build airstrips.
It makes no sense.
So now,
so for the debunkers to even say that
they're nuts,
what do you think those lines are then?
Those long straight lines,
they look like,
you know,
it looks like an airport.
There's absolutely no doubt in that that
But.
So for example,
look right now we've got a rover on Mars
that's,
you know,
driving around and it's leaving behind
these tracks.
So we're suggesting that at some point a
long time ago,
some type of an unmanned or possibly
even manned craft landed at Nassco for
to conduct a core drills and core
samples of the ground to determine
what's in that area because still today,
NASA is a bunch of drilled holes,
right?
Yes.
And there are you.
And there's still mining going on today
at Nasa because it's very abundant in a
very precious raw materials on earth.
So if you want to know about planet
earth,
you can go to NASA and by conducting a
few days of research you,
it's like the cliff notes of planet
Earth essentially.
And so imagine if you had a bunch of
natives there and all of a sudden this
thing lands that conducts a bunch of
research there,
of course,
afraid they run away.
And then this,
uh,
this craft leaves again and it leaves,
it has left behind some tracks in the
sand or on the ground.
And then they come back out and they
look at this stuff and they're like,
oh my God,
what just happened here?
I think we were just visited by God
doesn't create these funerary objects
that are 1000,
500 years old.
It looked like planes that are from
central and South America.
Doesn't it make more sense that they had
planes that someone had planes back
then?
Well,
yes,
of course.
I mean that is the suggestion that the
runways.
And that's what this whole multi Nazca
lines thing maybe it really isn't an
airport.
Look,
I'm always,
I'm always one to say,
never say never.
So I don't care.
Yeah,
exactly.
Flush and loved ones at that.
No,
but the thing is that,
you know,
the bottom line is that at Nassco,
what's really odd is that we have done
some research there were we found,
you know,
higher levels of arsenic in areas where
there shouldn't be any arsenic and very
bizarre magnetic fields there where you
can put down your compass and it keeps
on spinning and things like that at the
beginning and the end of this runway
looking like strips.
Excuse me.
And so something definitely happened
there because the whole idea that it was
very easy to build these things is
nonsense because people have suggested,
oh,
all you have to do is you have to
scratch off the surface of the,
off the off the ground,
and then you expose the lighter and
darker underground with the pebbles and
things like that.
We've tried that and people have tried.
It doesn't work that way.
So many things in Peru,
it's not just that,
oh no.
With Machu Picchu and the skulls,
those people that were forming their
heads,
what is the explanation for that?
They made their heads or an alien heads.
They flatten them out and them out
mountain.
Well and,
and here's the crazy thing that
archeology even has an answer to this.
And they say that the reason why,
and this was achieved by binding the
infant's head upon birth with the wooden
boards so that the brains or the,
the,
the skull brain chambers,
we would,
you know,
grow into this elongated fashion.
And the archeologists are saying,
well,
yes,
of course they did this because they
were mimicking or worshiping their gods.
And then they pat each other on the
shoulder and then they go home and say,
case solved mystery done.
We're out of here.
This is it.
And that is exactly where I say,
no,
this isn't that where the mystery is not
solved because the question is,
okay,
you just said,
but this was done in order to worship
the gods.
Well,
my question is,
who were these gods?
That is the question that the
archeologists are not answering.
Are there any images that they have of
these gods?
These,
for example,
it all over ancient Egypt,
which by the way did the Sgo deformation
phenomenon also happened in ancient
Egypt.
It happened in Germany.
It happened in Russia all around the
world.
Do we have these elongated skulls that
are obviously human in origin,
but they all have all these elongated
heads.
And then there are some scholars that we
don't know if they're really human in
origin.
I mean,
who knows that star child thing.
When you think about that,
is that a horseshit that for example?
I mean it's definitely something worth
looking into.
Absolutely.
There's no question in my mind,
but to return to the Eland,
you don't know about star child now.
Star child skull,
the they found it's really freaky
looking.
They've determined that it's human,
but it
might be human plus something else like
the mitochondrial Dna,
whatever the fuck it was.
I think it was determined that the
mother was human.
They don't know what father was.
Yeah.
This is just reading it online.
It could easily just be some horrible
birth defects.
It's,
it's to be debated,
but the thing,
it's definitely a fascinating story that
you know,
merits further investigation out of all
these sites.
Replaces,
haven't you been to?
I've been to most of them.
Eighty percent of them.
Ninety percent of them like.
No.
I mean I know there's definitely been
about to 75 percent of the stuff because
see that's the most mind blowing and
putting the Puente club.
Yeah,
I mean look for sheer size,
it's definitely the great pyramids on
the Giza plateau because have you been.
You must go.
I met.
He's been you.
So you know,
I've only been to you need,
so that's the only place I.
that's also crazy thing with the shadow
play in all this.
I mean,
you know,
when you stand in front of that pyramid,
you're breathless that you can't
breathe.
They're so incredible.
It's crazy about him is that you never
see the pyramids and the pictures that
you see,
you never see that there's like a ghetto
and Egypt and get on all around it and
you know what I mean?
They're just.
There's one side of the pyramid where
it's all open desert and then right
there you're in a ghetto and the cool
thing is when you drive around this
gallery owner and garbage,
but the pyramid is always visible
wherever you go.
So you've got this ancient monument and
then you place.
Yes,
exactly.
Drive bys cheap goat head.
What's cool about your job?
You have your job is so cool that if
there was ever a chick that was like a
little bit out of your league,
you could always saying it,
I'm going to Machu Picchu next week and
I want you to go with me.
Right?
What girl wouldn't doubt will.
We were saying that our Thomson girl,
if I was a chicken,
pretty willing to fuck,
I'm just telling me so much about Machu
Picchu,
men who are trying to deal closer right
there.
You have good genetics,
and we get traveled,
man,
a man with that kind of experienced sort
of a nerd,
but damn,
that's crazy hair and all of his
jewelry.
I do want to go to Easter island.
Who the Puma,
the Nazi symbol built into it.
Got One part.
I bet he has chicks laying it out.
You probably have chicks laying it out
on Easter island.
You know what I mean?
And and along the input,
put a swastika was a swastika and put
them up there because all around the
world,
in fact the swastika is,
has its origin in ancient India and
Hindu and good fortune.
Absolutely.
So the first telling people that now,
first of all,
they reversed the reverse that
direction,
but whatever.
I mean,
but the bottom line is they're ruined
that.
And the little mustache,
Michael Jordan tried to bring back that
a little monster.
So that's kind of an ego that
motherfucker has.
Maybe they reversed it to say,
sign of death instead of sign of good
fortune or
bad fortune gang.
They just stole it and it was also used
in ancient Greece.
I mean,
it's not the same.
They did reverse it.
Yes,
yes,
absolutely.
Symbolism is fascinating,
which is one of the most fascinating
things to me about the Egyptian language
that it was all symbols,
but instead of with us with letters and
each letter having a sound that what
they have is like symbols and he said
that apparently just absorbing the
language isn't interpreting and just has
a completely different experience in the
human mind.
You know these all these symbols.
We have symbols that we re register like
this is a McDonald's symbol,
this is citgo,
this but their language consistent of
these things and that is a completely
different experience than reading our
language and the ancient,
the incas had not.
They had string.
That was their language,
their.
That was their written language number.
Why they got jacked by the Spanish.
The Spanish came over and go,
Yo,
Yo writing string with a shop to giving
us a gold.
Let's get the gold for that motherfucker
on the ship.
That is rather because what wants the
gold ran out?
They started fucking slicing,
realizing that they weren't God's
anymore till they thought people on
horses were gods.
Well,
there's actually a little bit more to
that story and that is that get out.
That was,
it was toward the end that many Asian
cultures based their whole calendar on
the return of the gods.
And it just so happened that,
uh,
you know,
both Cortez and Pittsboro happened to
arrive on the shores in the same year.
Fucking lucked out is it?
Absolutely is,
was complete chance and need the beard
at the serpent.
The plume serpent doesn't that same
thing mean a bearded man isn't there
like a,
the,
the translation of Queso and Kukula con
is like,
like so similar to a man with a beard
and that,
you know,
this is one of the reasons why the
Aztecs were so baffled by these people
really are men with beards.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
I mean,
that's,
that's part of it,
but to me that's kind of,
it's very elitist in,
in a certain way because even though
those,
those theories have been proposed that
you know,
and all of a sudden a,
this redheaded guy appeared with a red
beard and things like that,
then that's why he was worshiped.
I mean,
I,
I don't think that people are or that,
you know,
the,
those coaches back then were so shallow.
I think it has more to do that this
quits bottler coopered con character.
If he was a redhead,
a guy that he flew around in this flute
flying or plumed or winged serpent and
that this winged serpent,
we all know that snakes do not fly and
so you need enough mushrooms.
They do,
Bro.
I can talk to you and see.
Here's the thing that you can't
attribute everything that a person sees
to mushrooms,
mushrooms,
because you've done enough mushrooms.
You can.
Yes.
Not.
Look,
I have to say something about yes.
No,
but the thing is that our collective
through our collective consciousness
today is way bigger than the collective
consciousness.
Back in the day.
How do we know?
Well,
because today if yes,
no,
I mean the thing is that you know today,
if we see if we see a spaceship or a
Ufo,
we can immediately recognize it as a
spaceship or a Ufo.
Back in the day,
if you didn't know what that was,
it doesn't matter how many mushrooms you
took,
you still have to describe it with
something that was a spark of
inspiration or a spark of something
that,
that motivated or inspired all these
stories.
So yes,
but how do we not know that what these
stories are is people's memory of
someone else who had seen people who
were flying around and it was thousands
and thousands of years ago over time,
but that's the story.
More and more diluted.
Well,
it goes back to heal and they and they
absolutely did.
They did get diluted.
That's the whole.
That's the whole idea that,
you know,
that's why we have,
Christianity today and Islam and all
those different things.
I believe you believe these depiction of
humanity,
that we were engineered from a lower
primates by some aliens to mine for
gold.
I subscribe to the sort of first,
uh,
as a part of that statement,
yes,
that,
that we came about through a direct
targeted mutation of our genes and that
that will be the ultimate proof by the
way,
the ultimate proof of visitation,
willing to be in a crash spaceship or a
finding a ray gun or something silly
like that,
but it'll be an hour.
It will be found in our own genes that
something happened in the past that did
not come by chance,
but haven't they already mapped out the
human genome is not how they understand
like the people,
white people mostly related to
neanderthals and they've definitely
figured out all these things.
Yes,
of course.
I mean there's definitely many,
many conclusions have been drawn,
but there's still some mystery in the
human genome.
Absolutely.
For example,
that,
you know,
95 percent of our human genome,
of our DNA makeup allegedly is junk.
I,
I completely disagree with that.
Just because we can't decipher those 95
percent yet doesn't mean that that 95
percent truly is garbage.
I think that in our lifetime and things
are going to change quickly though,
and no,
we were not create a slaves.
No,
absolutely don't believe that's again
and glue nonsense.
So they came and they just sort of
fucked with people and created what we
will do 5,000
years from now on another planet.
You know,
if,
if we want to experiment and I think
that,
you know,
good in the end always outweighs the bad
talk to the Indians.
They got checked well,
but seriously that,
you know,
you can definitely make an argument that
if we go out there that it won't be to
destroy others,
but you know,
in a benevolent way in
planet earth,
every single intelligent animal that's
less intelligent than us.
We've been slaved.
We fucked with dolphins,
Orca as monkeys,
chimps,
everything that we can fuck me,
fuck everything that we can eat.
We eat.
And that is the evidence of every other
intelligent life.
How it treats that other intelligent
life that it can manipulate like
dolphins killing other dolphins and
orcas killing dolphins,
orchids killing whales.
But I also think that that is why that
is the reason why we have not yet made
official contact with any type.
So we're not ready.
We're not.
You fucked too many animals.
I wonder what are the top,
the top five animals that we fuck as I
would say sheep number one donkeys.
That Colombian donkey show you ever
watch that chicken flock of chickens.
Dogs.
People fucked her dogs for sure.
Then the Dave Chappelle bit about.
Try to fuck him.
Fuck him.
Mcgee Mcgee.
It'll take off like a piece of celery
and throw it in the tall grass.
So in closing,
this isn't going crazy at the top five
right there.
Took us 20 fucking seconds.
It's not hard.
Jellyfish.
There was someone really crazy seated.
Enemy's enemy frog second pocket
flashlight.
Yeah,
for chimps,
right?
Tranquilizer.
I met through the front lines and just
to get off track.
I see that guy,
that congressman,
they got busted.
He's a furry apparently has been doing a
lot of weird shit.
He's kind of tiger costume.
Congressman Lou,
his,
his staff's trying to get him to resign.
I don't know if he's resigned yet.
It's,
it's inevitable,
but he's a.
apparently he's out of his fucking mind
dressing up like a tiger.
It's like one of those kids costumes.
Not even a cool cut tiger constantly.
Well,
that's what the firies were.
You know,
we've talked about furries in the
podcast before because I was in
Pittsburgh and they had a furry
convention at the same time that the UFC
was in Pittsburgh and all these firies
were wandering the streets and the
people in the hotel sent me hip to
furries because they go to Pittsburgh
every year.
So the,
uh,
the guys that are working in the hotel
tell you the nutty stories,
these people shitting and litter boxes
and some of the furry community actually
got upset with me that I was spreading
misinformation.
Well,
I say no,
you may not.
If you're a furry,
you may not be into the dirty aspect of
the furry,
but there's a broad spectrum of furry
behavior folks.
And just because you're not into taking
shits in letter boxes,
it doesn't mean that the man who worked
the West and didn't tell me that they
called down and asked to put a large
litter box in the lobby of the western
because the firies had every room in the
western.
So they wanted a litter box.
One,
one litter box for everyone.
Yeah.
The Guy who,
uh,
I asked the guy who was delivering the
food and the room service guy,
he said that they asked for bose like
the feet on the ground,
like d,
like dog bowls,
like big bowls and what?
All their food in bowls.
And then they go over there.
The bowls are on the ground,
like bowls of milk,
fast for large bulk.
They eat like an animal.
And this dude's a congressmen.
There's,
we're,
we're so up the ass of politicians that
there's no one left but crazy people.
There's no one left.
But Michele Bachmann's,
you've got to be completely had to
fucking lunch to want to be the
president of this country.
Coming from the alien guy that's saying
a lot Thursday,
ancient aliens.
The premier of season three.
Good luck with that,
sir.
Thank you very much for coming on the
podcast and if you want to follow
Giorgio on twitter,
it's sucralose.
T S O u k a l a l l o s o s.
I'm going to say it again.
I'm going to ps,
this is sucralose at t s o u k a l o s.
nice.
Got It.
And Eddie,
I'm going to be an El Paso.
A 10th planet El Paso this Saturday go
to 10th planet.
Jj,
you gotta reschedule,
right?
You got sick.
I got sick last weekend so I rescheduled
it for this Saturday at 10:00
at j.
j.com.
And get on the forum.
That's the name of my phone.
10th 10th clowns.
Jujitsu.
We love it.
That's great man.
We named it.
Well now you're a high talking about
Zechariah Bureau judo,
Jujitsu and then it sounded too weird.
Junk on the planet.
I'm not stupid.
Two minutes later I thought,
damn,
that sound way better than me,
so I named my beer then be really for
them.
That's where all the information you
Jitsu history bitches.
August 13th,
I will be in Milwaukee With Mad Flavor,
Aka Joey Diaz at the PAPP's theater.
Tickets are still available.
They are going fast though.
And then September 23rd at the paramount
in Denver.
Holla at your boy and that is the last
time I checked those have sold out
already.
And um,
it's only been on sale for a couple of
days.
Denver showing mad love.
Can't wait to get back to Colorado
before the end of the earth for the
civilization corrodes.
And that's where I live.
I turned away because I'm going to
travel through space.
Speed of light.
Come back 13,000
years.
There's a lot of shit that happened in
this podcast and not a lot of.
It was good.
A lot of it was strange.
Brian fell asleep at least five times.
I noticed it.
Eddie Bravo.
I'm just drunk off it.
Any questions before we leave for this?
Man?
You were fucking chomping at the bit to
get in here on this podcast.
I was just,
I want her to sit and listen to him
talk.
I know we got into dirty shit at the
end,
so I feel like he corrupted enough.
We did.
We did enough damage to Zam.
Beautiful.
Alright.
Thank you everybody.
Thanks for tuning in.
That's it for this week.
We'll be back next week.
We're trying to rub it together with Jay
Moore.
He was busy this week and next week
probably Joe Diaz and Duncan trussell.
We'll see you soon.
Thank you.
And thank you to the fleshlight is if
you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the fleshlight
and enter in the code name Rogan,
you will get 15 percent off the number
one sex toy for men and then you can
shoot loads in it and take naps and you
would feel so good and is a discount.
All right,
see you freaks.
We're soon.